[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show i'm
going to skip my usual preamble because
i'm fidgeting in my seat
i am extremely excited about this
conversation and i don't want to hear
myself talk so my guest today why would
i be so excited this is sebastian rooten
better known as boss brewton you can
find him on twitter and elsewhere at
bossrootin mma is a dutch american actor
former mixed martial artist kickboxer
and professional wrestler he was a ufc
heavyweight champion and a three-time
king of pancras world champion we're
going to talk quite a bit about that
finishing his career on a 22-fight
unbeaten streak with a strike accuracy
of 70.6 percent the highest ever
recorded by fightmetric
rootin was co-host of inside mma on axis
tv that's a-x-s from
2007-2016 and he has been a color
commentator in several mma organizations
including pride fighting championships
another thing that we will spend some
time on he has appeared in numerous
television shows movies and video games
as an actor and continues to be involved
in mma through his coaching and
publishing of instructional materials
boss became a naturalized american
citizen in the late 1990s and in 2015 he
was inducted into the ufc hall of fame
we'll link to all of the social as well
as the o2 trainer which we're going to
get to you can find that on instagram at
o2 long trainer and we'll link to
youtube facebook and other places boss
welcome to the show it's nice to see you
oh very good to see you tim thank you so
much for having me
i gotta tell you just a little story
before we hop in and it's gonna tie into
a lot of things so
i rarely turn into a heavy breathing
fanboy with these types of conversations
but i have to tell you that
one of the most transformative
experiences of my life was
in 1992 my first travel outside of the
united states was to japan where i
became an exchange student
and i wore a school uniform every day of
school
and on my way to school i would always
stop at this particular bookstore
because they had a magazine called
kakuto tsushi
and i started becoming fascinated by
by something called well you know shuto
of course which was founded by sayama
satoru and then i would also follow
u
wf and these really bizarre pro
wrestling circuits because i saw a video
from a friend of mine this is
pre-internet
where there appeared to be real
knockouts occasionally and there
appeared to be real contact
and then this thing called pancras comes
out and i was following this because i
knew a few of the people or knew of a
few of the people involved like funaki
which i'll definitely want to ask you
about and i remember
the very first fight that i saw you in
which ended in less than a minute
opponent 50 pounds heavier
and
i've just remembered the deafening
silence
in the arena at one point because no one
really knew what to do
and uh that was my introduction to boss
rooting so i have followed you for a
very very very long time and it's a real
pleasure to connect
in person so i just had to get that off
my chest that's awesome
yeah it's been a long time coming
and perhaps we could just
begin with a question that i've always
wondered why is there or why does there
appear to be such
a strong martial arts tradition in the
netherlands because when i landed in
japan that was the first thing that i
was not expecting so there's peter arts
ernesto hoost you had
all of these dutch fighters people
absolutely loved ramon decker for
instance and even going further back i
learned because i did judo as my sport
which was mandatory
that
the dutch had this incredible history of
judo wins going back to the earliest
olympic games where does that come from
i have no clue i believe because you're
such a small country and we really like
the people in the world to know that we
exist maybe
i mean the kickboxers
they have to be the the best dutch i
remember the story from uh well the
trainer from host you already honest you
mentioned him young plus and you won
foss there were two guys and they went
with their team like rob cayman all
these guys at the time i was huge fans
of those they went to thailand and they
got their butt kicked like really bad
and then they realized wait a minute
predominantly they're only kicking so
what if we do western boxing and we
combine that with kicks you know in
order to set up the cakes
and boom the dutch kickboxing was born
and suddenly everybody started just
demolishing the ties i mean your bobbin
deckers you touched on him as well he
was he was my idol he was a good friend
of mine as well
unfortunately he passed away
a bunch of years ago
but he was like pound-for-pound i would
say the most powerful guy he was the
first guy
who became the fighter of the year in
thailand that always went to a thai guy
but he was so good that they couldn't go
without it they have to take him and for
him when you see him fighting koban a
guy over 200 matches never been knocked
out and he was the first guy to knock
him out and the whole place lumpini
stadium champion gets quiet and you see
rob cameron jumping in the ring with the
dutch flag and he's waving it around i
know what he says
dude it blew my mind that was the reason
i started training at the same gym mang
ho that was rahman dagger so yeah i
truly believe it's we have natural
heavyweights we have the tallest people
in the world so i think that translates
really what to k1 and glory because
that's predominantly heavyweight boxing
at the time the kickboxing
and then just a dutch style that just
tied everything together nowadays
everybody it's like brazilian jiu jitsu
right at the beginning nobody knew but
now everybody knows that it's the same
at the dutch kickboxing now pretty much
everybody's doing it
so let's flash back to childhood just to
paint a picture for folks because people
who've seen your highlight videos like
my god this guy's a savage machine
but let's go back and perhaps
if you wouldn't mind just describe a bit
your childhood and what you were like as
a child
because i had no
knowledge of this until i started doing
research for this conversation but if
you could just describe yourself as a
kid
i think that would be helpful for
setting the stage
when i was born i came out apparently
full with eczema but that went away
and then at four years old i contracted
rheumatic fever
which was the best of the two because it
was either leukemia or that so
thankfully it was that i took four
months in the hospital and then when i
was six years old we moved to a village
and that's when my eczema came back
together with severe asthma now my
eczema was really bad i had to wear
gloves long sleeves turtlenecks because
i had it in my neck i was the lapper in
school that's what they called me hey
aleppo watch out you don't scratch if i
would do this watch out your ears don't
fall off you know constantly there i was
bullied on a daily basis
but you know when i was 12 i saw we were
on a vacation in france and i saw this
movie enter the dragon it was 17 years
and older to get in but my brother and i
we found a way to sneak in for free and
we were too young for the movie and
that's where i saw bruce lee
and
boy that that was it i realized that if
i would be like that guy because he was
also a skinny guy i was a skinny guy
because of my ass i had these horrible
aspects
then the building would probably stop
because then i could defend myself so it
took me two years to convince my parents
to uh to start martial arts and then
after two years they just they gave up
because that was every day i would ask
him and finally they broke they say okay
just just go
and i was fortunate to um live next to
uh two beautiful neighbor girls and one
of the girls was dating the coolest guy
in town xavier xavier that's how you
pronounce it in holland and and he took
me onto the swing he was always helping
me a little bit because i had these
things with birds i was always in the
trees i was swinging trees but i had
these birds that can't pick me up from
school i mean they were so tame they
would always sit on my shoulder wherever
i went even in the shower it was amazing
and he brought me to the adult taekwondo
classes
and within months i started beating some
of the adults of course not the black
belts but i started dropping big guys
and i overheard this guy talking about
me in the dressing room man did you see
that kid bossy dropped jack with a
freaking spinning back kick to the head
whoa everybody laughing man that kid has
a lot of talent you know as a kid when
you only hear bad things about you when
suddenly people start talking good
things about you you tend to listen to
the adults
and that led to the first street fight
the biggest bully in my school shockey
was his name
again i was riding my bicycle on the
street and there he came with six seven
of his buddies and hey leper whatever
they were screaming and this time i
shouted something back
and i heard him laugh i look back and
sure if they started to chase me and i
told myself this is it i'm not gonna do
it anymore so i put my bike on the stand
on the sidewalk
they came surrounded me with the bikes i
always have to laugh about it because in
the movies this is like in the scene at
night they do it with cars and the
headlights are the lighting for the
fight you know but this was with my
science with the young kids
and then shaki started pushing his chest
to me and challenging me telling me that
i had to hit him
so i did and then i realized that the
bullies weren't really that strong it
took one punch which is weird by the way
because i was doing taekwondo which is
90 kicking
so i knocked them out one punch nose was
broke that was a problem because now the
police was called and they showed up at
my mom and dad's doorstep and that
verified you know you see they always
thought that martial arts was violence
now i have to in in protection of my
parents i never told them i was bullied
my mom had a lot of trouble with me
every night i had to be
mummified as what we call it you know
creams and cortisones and put a redmi
all around the whole family would send
in old bed sheets which you would wrap
up to bandages and then in the middle of
night i would scratch it off because it
would itch so bad she had to do it again
so she had so much work with me i never
wanted to bother with her that i was
bullied because i'm pretty sure that if
my dad would have known
i don't think he would have said take
him off i i believe he would have said
keep him on there because this is good
for him so but that's that's where
everything came from because then i
realized wait a minute that was easy you
know so now i went after the bullies it
always blew i literally made a list i
went every single one of them adam and
other kids in school who got bullied
guess who took care of that problem you
know now i was the bully the bully guy i
took care of all the bullies though and
that was it my mom and dad they took me
off what i said from taekwondo but then
when i was 20 i moved out of the house
immediately i started doing karate
not re of realizing it was not full
contact
so then i started thai boxing within six
months and then within three months i
started competing thai boxing and one
thing led to another and bada bing bada
boom now i'm here talking to you
now here you are
what do you make of the birds i actually
want to hear a little bit more about
that that's like saint francis of assisi
how did that happen or how do you
explain that
i had no friends everybody thought i was
contagious so my time was spending in
the trees i was three four hours a day
in the forest we had a forest the front
of our home we had a big forest and i
was always climbing trees i could
literally coat throughout the whole
forest maybe i had to go four or five
times down from tree top to treetop i
would swing which came in handy with
bullies if they started to chase me i
just climbed the tree and then they
climbed it to it i started swinging to
the other tree that the bullies tried to
do it and then one guy and a big guy one
time he fell down
and his head next to a big rock
and that of course they got out and
suddenly everybody nobody wanted to
chase me anymore so yeah that was it and
that was my contact also with birds i
always was mesmerized with birds
and i found this nest
from uh oh what do you call them here a
jackdaw that's what you call them here a
cow is in dutch and i i i took one out i
knew you had to do it with gloves
because if you put a human scent on it
then they might push the other ones out
so i had this plastic glove that i went
and took one out and now you become the
dad you know so you start feeding it and
it's amazing man it's it's so cool
because they
you're there for the first flight i mean
every time they go down they crash they
crash they're like steve austin the six
million dollar man on the moon right but
now that's not because there's one day
that he goes and he goes
and he starts going up
and they're so excited they start
perhaps and start screaming and
that was the sound i used to make and
wherever i was he would pick me up from
school this guy he would know in what
room i was
and then just uh he was sitting in front
of the teachers got really angry because
he was constantly ah hey he would see me
in the class and then afterwards he
would sit on my steering wheel for my
bicycle or on my shoulder he was always
with me
wow
so i must say that doing
prep for this conversation has made me
laugh so many times
i mean if you didn't exist someone would
have to invent you
for a novel or a movie
so the couple of things i just want to
check on so the first
is that
i read after enter the dragon
one of the first things you did was make
a set of nunchaku from two pieces of
wood and some chain the line that i
wanted to just confirm here it says
they became an important accessory for
the young boss and he carried them
around his neck even to the local
grocery store is that accurate
that's accurate but they were very
dangerous because they didn't use any
screws just like with the like you know
you have those how do you say nails like
kirk nails so if i would go to hockey i
would just let go it was super dangerous
because i could smash somebody's face by
accident
and kung fu shoes okay where i had this
kung fu
all right shoes
comfort shoes and nunchucks with nails
doesn't sound safe no now we we don't
have to spend a lot of time on the next
one but just so people can appreciate
just the full picture so
i ask all guests
if they can send any exploratory bullets
that might be interesting and there are
a couple of them that we're going to
explore but one that i just want to
mention and we're not gonna we don't
have to spend a lot of time on it but
one of the bullets you sent was was
drunk slipped when i came out of the
shower and broke a toilet with my head
when falling backwards this was in
hawaii my whole floor started floating
very funny story no clue how my skull
didn't break i guess i hit a weak spot
yes so you're one of a kind in terms of
the bullets
that i've received here one of which
came out of left field well i mean a lot
of them came out of left field but one
was your original profession as a
culinary chef went to four years of
culinary school so i did not know this
yeah how did that happen and then when
did it end
i always wanted to be a chef i was
mesmerized with it when i was young kid
already and that went away because the
martial arts started coming along i
really liked that but i still was
working as a chef
as a cook no i was not a chef in a
restaurant i was the sous chef
it stopped because i was working for a
guy for three years
and uh i would i would run the whole
kitchen only on the weekends he had to
come by like my my claim to famous i did
42 people one night all different people
with with an appetizer main course and a
dessert and i did it all by myself so i
was always i liked those kind of
challenges i never wanted to call him in
because he was living in the house next
to it i always wanted to do it myself
and on tuesdays we had maybe the most
people we ever had was eight
never we had more people so i would make
preparation for 20 just to make sure
double it up and then some
and then uh one day
a cycling group came and suddenly it was
full and and there was not enough
preparation i run to the house i said
you got to come and help me and he gets
in my face while i'm well i need to cook
for these people i say listen it's okay
you're angry i got it i understand it
it's weird because we never had this
amount of people but why don't we do
this after this is over you know okay so
right now we have to get out these
people and he started screaming and he
kept going and he says you do whatever i
say i do do and i said well that's
actually not true
you're not controlling me you say oh no
and he grabbed a big bowl of butter
and he says if i throw this on the
ground and i tell you to clean it up
you're going to clean it up so i walked
over to him i hit the ball under his
hand and he got all over the ground and
said ask me
and he said
and i took my apron off i go good luck
with the people bye and i remember at
the time i had a pager that was at the
time and he kept paging me i go dude
what i did for you in those three years
and then just to fire at me that that
was it and that's when i stopped working
and i started focusing more on martial
arts i was also believing or not this is
really what i'm going to say now a model
i was a model
and i that was controlled by three women
who had a model agency a new model
agency and they love me i was working
three four days a week i was making
twelve hundred dollars twelve photos
guilders at the time which is a lot of
money if you're 20 years old but you
know once i started doing martial arts
as well that's of course when i had hair
i started showing up for the shiner here
and there and they didn't really love
that and that was the end of that job as
well so that's how i lost both of these
jobs
okay
well you're very proactive in uh
terminating one of them
[Applause]
yeah yes so let's let's talk about if
this makes sense as a next step
pancras and
pancrasa i'm not even sure how you say
it in english frankly because i always
heard in japanese
how did that happen and what was that
experience
like for you
in the beginning for you know leading
into it and then first fight let's just
say
okay so i get a little background story
really fast
i was a kickboxer and i knocked
everybody out and then i got bored i
thought it was a great job to to become
a bouncer
yeah think about that so i became a
bouncer but it was of course not a
really healthy lifestyle because at five
o'clock we close and then we go to the
after parties you know what everything
bad goes after that
so on one of those parties apparently i
talked to a promoter
after two years of not competing and not
living a healthy lifestyle
because it was this new guy frank lopman
the animal was his name was a kickboxer
who came was released from prison and he
was gonna resume his fighting career if
i wanted to fight him and i go with my
drunk hat i go sure
so but i have no clue of this whole
conversation and then in february they
gave me a call and they asked me where
to send the posters to i said the
posters i said from what he says from
the fight i said who's fighting i say
you i say whoa who am i fighting he says
frank lopman i said the animal and he
goes yeah i go when did i say that and
he goes you don't remember we
anyway i realized oh i said yes to the
guy i said okay when is the fight
it wasn't two and a half weeks
now listen i couldn't vote skip for 20
minutes my first class that's how bad i
was
i was gonna needless to say i lost that
fight and what the dutch audience forgot
all about by all the knockouts they
focused only on that fight and it kind
of chewed me out to spit me out so i
said okay this is it i don't want to do
it anymore but my martial arts was
always there i wanted to do something
with it then my teacher my karate
teacher came up with this crazy idea to
do choreographed fight scenes like we go
in spandex we're all pumped up buddies
you go to a night club at midnight they
close the lights it gets dark suddenly
the high pitch music starts stroboscope
and we come up with backflips and we do
all this crazy stuff we start fighting
each other and high level stuff we get
cigarettes out of the mouth cups
spinning backings breaking new chucks we
did everything right
and that became suddenly a thing
suddenly we start doing it in more
nightclubs and then suddenly we started
doing other big events thai boxing
events in the break and then it became a
european show and we started traveling
to europe and every game touch tv
european tv and on one of these shows
i was always going to the ring with
backflips and at the end making
somersault the back up and then i would
jump in the ring and we'd do our show
and chris doleman he was the godfather
of mixed martial arts so to say in all
the free fighting actually that's what
they called it at the time
and he stopped me after the show and he
says listen i know you're from thai
boxing you're an animal you know and now
i see you doing all these crazy
acrobatics i mean i think you're a
perfect fit to be a free fighter i go
what's free fighting and they explained
me the rules that pretty much anything
would go i said okay sure so i went to
his gym a few times but it's far away
was in amsterdam it's like a two and a
half hour drive you know especially when
there's traffic so it didn't really work
but one day the telephone went and this
was really weird oh and by the way i met
my wife in 92 in in
february 92 and she was looking at me
weird one day she had this really weird
look i go what's going on she says
you're going to be a famous fighter in
japan
and i go no i told you i'm not going to
fight anymore she says i know but you
said holland you're going to go to japan
so a year and four months later i get
the phone call
and normally i never picked up the phone
and my answering machine was broke
somehow i picked up the phone and it was
chris dolman he says you got to jump in
the car right now because there's this
new organization called pancreas there's
two guys here suzuki minoru and funaki
mazakatsu who are scouting they're
looking for fighters maybe this is great
for you but she can make her money you
know he says okay so i jumped in the car
went over there
and he had an organization rings and one
of his guys was the rings champion and
we just needed to spar they just wanted
to show technique but that guy just went
really hard so i told him to slow down i
said listen it's not necessary to try to
knock each other out just let's relax
and show technique
i think that he believed that i was
afraid so he turned it up so i stopped
him again and i said listen i'm okay
with this but it's not going to be
one-way traffic you have to understand
so of course now it was on i was sure
though because i hiked him in the face
right away
he went down needed a whole bunch of
stitches and that's it i saw funaki
suzuki pointing at me
and they said we want him and then later
when i
found out why they wanted me also one of
the reasons was that i was able to jump
i could stand in front of the rope from
the ring and the rope would be here and
i would
stand still jump over the rope
to go in the ring and they thought it
was so impressive that was also the
reason that they wanted me as a fighter
go that's the weirdest reason i've ever
heard but anyway the fight was september
21st 1993
and you have to understand i was from
holland so
you know with us everything is small we
drive everywhere like going to paris
that's the same drive as we're going
from california to vegas you know so we
drive hit by car i've never been on a
plane now i'm on a 13-hour plane and i'm
coming japan and you already touched it
on it i was weird there was no way in
and i thought that was so weird why is
there no way in well i the guy i'm
fighting is japanese and apparently
they're very honest people so he will be
on weight and then i go
did we talk about it
i didn't know anything what we were
going to do and on the day of the fight
i'm walking in there
and this tall guy walks up to me and he
shakes my hand oh you're the promoter he
goes no i'm fighting you i go you're
fighting me i go what is your weight
yeah and he was much happier than i was
and i go oh that is so weird and then
the promoter walked up and i said excuse
me oh you're the promoter yeah i said is
he not too heavy he says no mr root and
everybody fights everybody so i tried to
force a smile to go yeah that's awesome
i said oh by the way before you look how
many rounds are we fighting and he goes
one round i go one round that's awesome
how many minutes and he goes 30.
so no break fighting a guy's much
heavier than i am in a 30 30-minute
match i was like whoa so i started doing
these things because i was a very
aggressive fighter in holland like i
would be very technical until somebody
touched me and then i would just destroy
him and because i was very explosive i
could get away with it but i guess the
good guy like peter earth was a very
close friend of mine already was 40 so
thankfully i never had to face him that
would be a problem against a guy like
that because i wasn't it didn't really
click yet you always have these dojo
fighters and you have fighters in dojo
they're really good but they can't bring
that game under pressure to a fight it's
really hard to separate that too like it
doesn't matter how good you are in
training
the fighting with the pressure that's
the test and i didn't have that yet but
now i'm in japan and i'm a 30 minute
fight and i'm thinking if this guy's
gonna hit me and i'm gonna unload on him
and i can't put him away because they're
very known to take a lot of damage these
guys have to keep on fighting i'm gonna
be in trouble so i put these big rs on
my hands with the with the marker are
from relax but in all of this rustic
starts also coincidentally with an r
which means the same
and my corner i never had a coach so i
always had my manager with me and i said
the only thing when he hits me
just shout relax relax that's the only
thing i want you to do you know because
i'm a hobbit let's take the risk
thankfully it went really well
uh you talked about it in the opening i
knocked him out because he was taller
than i i palm strike him under his head
he went down and you had eight counts
there
and he got up so now i turn it up so
since his hands were high i full kicked
him to the body brought the hands down
then i hit him again and while he went
down i kneed him in the face
and then it became very scary you know
he uh he didn't wake up for two days it
was a very scary thing thankfully he got
out of it they became actually a good
friend of mine but that was the deciding
factor if i was going to fight or not i
say if i told my wife if she's not going
to come out this is it i don't want to
do this anymore and i remember after the
fight people cheering for me and and i
remember a couple had a baby there who
brings a baby to a fight but the baby
was there and they put the baby in my
hand making pictures i felt like i was
the president there with the baby
wasting a fever flexing
it was the wildest experience and then
the next day i'm walking on the street
and every 10 15 people or so they start
bowing to me and i'm going what is going
on here and then i passed the newspaper
stance and on the cover was me hanging
in the splits something i didn't even
know i was doing i was so euphoric i
guess i jumped to the splits to all
corners which became my trademark later
on the root and jump
and i was hanging in the splits in the
air and my guy was knocked out below me
on the ground i go oh okay so this is
how these people are recognizing me one
day
the other day suddenly i was just a
known guy it was the weirdest experience
ever so i remember that cover
this is
this is what i saw at the newsstand it's
bringing back all these memories in
kishijo's a place called sun road i
remember the whole thing it's so wild
that we're even talking i gotta say it's
really surreal for me right now
so let's
go back for a second
your wife saying you're gonna be famous
in japan did she ever explain or
describe what she felt that brought that
up or how that came up for her
no but you know what weird was then in
94 she had the same look and i
immediately recognized it and i say now
what and she said we're gonna move to
america and you're gonna be in the tv
business
tim i had a show for nine years on tv we
did inside mma for nine years 431 live
shows i mean and that was the same thing
and then two years later
we're in america and now i'm fighting in
america and then i got into a tv show it
was it just came to her she just said it
and both he said the third time i said
we gotta see numbers here honey they're
like eight numbers or whatever the lotto
is we need those numbers so please the
next time tell me that
could you describe for folks who haven't
seen this we'll put links in the show
notes for people who want to see
highlights and some full fights from
pancras what were the rules in pancreas
you alluded to the
the round in the very very long round
yeah what were some of the other rules
so what they did this these rules were
completely tailor-made for the japanese
fighter the japanese fighters are really
they're really good on the ground right
and not as good strikers so what they
did they said open head strikes because
open-end strikes make sure they have no
gloves on which makes it much easier to
go for chokes and four leg clocks and
all that stuff not only that they will
put your shoes on and get skin
protection
shoes for leg locks it's a nightmare i
mean you you can't escape blackhawks
it's much harder to escape when you wear
a shoe so that was totally tailor made
for them what they didn't know is that
as a bouncer i was fighting with palm
strikes because i was i saw my buddies
you know if you fight multiple guys it's
not like you start aiming for the jaw
you know you just hit whatever you can
hit and if you hit a skull or you're
going to break your hand so i started
palm striking everybody and
clotheslining what i always called it
you know my forearm i would this part
hit him in the neck you know the inside
of the forearm yeah and it would uh
perfect so then when i came there i go
this is easy i can already do it they
also had eight counts and then they had
this really weird thing which some
people because of that people thought it
was pro wrestling that like rope escapes
so that means if i would for instance
get you in the choke but if he could
touch the rope i had to let him go
now now people go yeah that's not real
fighting but
listen to this because that's why i
believe truly believe like that small
organization pancras i think we had
eight ufc champions i mean all these
guys became good and i believe that is
the reason because when you look at my
record i have 11 knockouts at 14
submissions
but if you if you read about my
submission i actually have 51
submissions because i would submit a guy
and then he would touch the rope and let
him go now for that for him it's the
same as getting an eight count so if the
fight goes the distance and he grabbed
the rope one time he's gonna lose you
know or if he went down one time he's
gonna lose as well so it's kind of the
same as an eight count
but because of that now you restart back
on your feet and you have another fight
like my last fight the guy that i docked
out put in a coma the first guy i fought
him the second time and i broke my
points on the very first you see the
very first punch i submitted him five
times so now
now i have five submissions so you have
way more ring time in there so all these
guys from japan who went to
to the ufc they all became ufc champions
it was the wildest thing i mean aventana
ken shamrock frank sherman murray smith
guy match i mean all these guys myself
included we all became ufc champs and we
were from that little small organization
pancras so and i believe that's because
of the rules
it's incredible
can you explain to me i've i've never
had a chance to ask someone this
question do you have any idea why the
japanese referred to him as wayne
shamrock and then he's ken shamrock in
the us
i believe it was because he did pro
wrestling in japan as well
under on the ken shamrock and they
wanted to steer away from that and
that's his middle name for what i
believe
ken wayne shamrock and that's why they
went with wayne shamrock got it
how would you describe funaki i've
always wondered ever since i was a young
kid because he seemed like he was
he seemed again my impression was
comparing him to suzuki that he was
really
thinking deeply about a lot of things
but that was just
the impression of a 15 year old
how would you describe the two of those
maybe starting with
funaki
funaki has always been a good friend of
mine
he helped me a lot
there's a whole conspiracy thing going
on but also with me though because
when i fought i i was the first guy to
beat suzuki right
i had two fights in one month so i told
my wife hey why don't you come with me i
stay in japan because i finally have
some training partners because i didn't
have any training partners over in
holland
so um i trained there and i the only
thing i asked for him was to how can i
stop a knee bar because i know ken is
really good with that how do i stop a
knee bar and he taught me one way now if
i tell a person how to stop a knee bar
it's very simple i say hold the leg so
he can snap it over that's it that
whatever happens you cannot make a knee
bar it's very simple i won't go into the
detail because a lot of people don't
understand it but it's a very basic
thing but he didn't say that
so in the fight when i fight ken
he uh he sits in the position for a
leglock and i'm already having my
defense ready to stop the leg and now he
threw his leg over my head which was
something that funaki didn't tell me and
i thought that was weird because then i
found out that these guys go six years
back and they always pro wrestled with
each other and i was always in the back
of my head did he say that to him
because why wouldn't he say hey just
hold his leg because then he can never
step over no he would give me one way
how to stop it
again well he used a different way but
still it didn't really matter because he
was always a very friendly guy suzuki
too he's a very nice guy always had a
great time with him and that's why he
was so out of character like for ducky
was my first loss he beat me by way of a
toehold and then for the people at home
they go like a toehold yeah this is not
that they grab a toe trust me i saw
somebody break a shin bone with a
toehold it's a very nasty move
and he got me into that and then many
years later when i became the champion i
had my rematch against fornacki
and i remember in the fight before the
fight
he comes up to me and this was so out of
character and i think he did it for the
audience and he would be on this
distance and he does this to me which
slits his throat with the thumb across
the throat yeah and i'm looking at my
management you go
i'm going to kill him now you know what
i mean and he goes oh you've got to stay
calm i said don't worry i'll stay calm
but you watch if i connect oh i'm going
to go to town and that that became my
best fight in pancras actually that's
for funaki they say that as well because
he was so tough i mean i have black and
blue palms i have bruises on my knees
from kneeing him and hitting him in the
face and every time he went down the
public started chanting he will get up
again he wipes his blood off yeah and
then he starts fighting and i gotta shut
up you know it's because every time he
got back up and then the last one was
that i had him by his hair he had long
hair i just grabbed his hair and i
drilled a knee in the face as hard as i
could and thankfully he stayed down that
time that was the end of the fight but
always wondered why would he have done
that i i had to be for the audience
because he was a very respectful guy
i remember that fight and it was like
there were a number of thoughts going
through my head as i watched this fight
number one
i've never seen
someone
take
so much
brutality and get up that many times and
i remember his face at the end i mean it
looked like a cabbage patch kid
with like
who had freddy krueger come after him i
mean it was just an absolute mess like
his eyes were swollen shut
and
i remember just being dumbfounded after
watching that fight yeah how was their
english i mean presumably you guys
communicated in english yeah was their
english okay or how was their
communication
were pretty okay
especially for daki he was always a
better english speaker he also did some
movies in in hollywood i actually was in
a movie with him we did and uh
with uh oh man pat morichita you know
from the karate kids
scientist in the movie yeah so yeah he
was already focusing on that he knew
that you know to in order to to to reach
the people outside the country you're
gonna have to learn to speak the
language so he was
really good with his english suzuki a
little less
in that era let's just say
92 to sort of 2000
in that range could be a little bit
earlier but let's just say when you
first got to japan onward are there any
japanese fighters
who impressed you who you think are
probably not known or lesser known in
the us did anybody stand out to you
yeah i always do a yuki kondo was good
shibuya he was a tough fighter i had a
draw against him one time was my only
draw and then the second time i i told
everybody i was going to finish him with
the boss with the neck crank i just came
up with a move and that's how i beat him
so that was kind of cool he was a tough
guy funaki was good suzuki was a little
physically not as super strong but he
made that up with technique he was
really fast on the ground i mean he
would jump all over the place
those were i think yeah the toughest
takahashi takahashi was what that was
the
i would call him he was a party guy like
me you know after the fights we became
good friends
that was so bad what happened was
i fought him and the day before i fought
him we saw this giant screen on the
building we saw a preview from the fight
the next day so imagine this we're
walking on the street and it goes hybrid
wrestling pancreas and we're looking and
they go boom and the first thing we see
is me knocking somebody out my first
fight i mean oh my god there's the
preview for tomorrow you know for the
show we have and i see somebody sitting
in half guard and he goes for an
inverted he look which at that time i
didn't know this is actually how i got
my fifth degree cue christine because
john blooming is standing behind me and
he's the highest gaijin the foreigner
for maso
he's like 12 degree and and john
blooming is 11 degrees so he's really up
the ladder
and i look at john and i go like well
that's a cool move i should remember
that and the next day i'm finding i'm in
a position
and i go give it a shot you know so at
least i never did it before i had no
clue
the amount of pressure i put on and i
broke his boat enough
so yeah he that was bad because he went
to the hospital he got an infection in
it i mean i think he was five months in
the hospital and it was a tough day when
i went to visit him that was really not
fun the poor guy and after that yeah
unfortunately he never came back as he
was before because he was a wild man he
was also taking risk taking shots he was
an exciting fighter always going for the
knockout but yeah unfortunately that i
think that kind of stopped it
what was it like being involved with
pride because i've heard so many rumors
about pride even
i i mean the japanese had lots of rumors
too and
i'll just leave it at that i mean
what was it like being involved with
pride
everybody when they're walking around
we're like this you know you go like
this oh yeah he's making fingers yeah
missing fingers yeah exactly exactly so
yeah
please tell just any stories about pride
because i've always wanted to ask
somebody
bright was just an organization that was
way ahead of the ufc
they were the biggest martial arts mixed
martial arts
organization on the planet we're talking
about a small show forty five thousand
people that's considered the small show
and it was the saitama super arena and
the saitama super arena was an arena
that you could also expand which hold 49
000 people i mean we did one time in an
open space 91 and a half thousand people
we had it was the most bizarre thing and
then they had no you know you see a guy
like bob sapp coming up who's 350 pounds
10 body fat
giant guy fighting a 180 pound guy you
know they made this crazy matchup but
the people loved it they ate it up and
it was always back then the miracle
croco fedora emilianenko the nogara
brothers i mean van der ley silva
quinton rampage x all these guys i
remember when
dana white challenged
the best fighters from pride
to a fight against chuck liddell who was
the champion at the time and i remember
chuck him over
with dana and that was the saitama super
arena and when the opening started i'm
sitting in my commentating table i'm
looking back and i see dana is little
bit smart open and he sees that i'm
looking at him i go and he goes
he's never seen a thing like that before
yeah that was crazy you know and then
with chuck he fought rick quint and
rampage jackson and and quinton won that
fight so now suddenly that was a big
gamble they took the ufc now they put
pride even more on the map but in the
meanwhile i always stole pride fighting
championship we got to go to america we
got to go to america no no we're doing
good here i said no no no it's nothing
compare what you go to america america
is where the big money is that's where
you want to be and they always declined
the decline and declined it then
suddenly the ultimate fighter came out
and that bumped the ufc up to the number
one spot and now suddenly they realized
they wanted to go to america and they
couldn't get through the atlantic
commission it didn't work you did it and
every time i say let me talk to the
catheter commission i have a good way to
talk to people they know me anyway you
know just let me talk but they know no
no and then at the end they go okay can
you talk to them
tim i walked in i did my whole talk and
they said oh we're splitting hairs
harrier okay yeah it's legal you can
come to america and i looked at them i
said you could have done this two years
ago and then you had the chance at least
to catch up to the ufc but by now the
ufc was this juggernaut that nobody
could touch anymore so people started
slowly what's your different pride yeah
that pride got evolved you know they
found out that uh
that it was maybe kind of a laundering
thing for the yakuza which is the mafia
that's why we were talking about the
half of pinkies you know and then of
course the
tokyo tv pulled out because you can't
have that that's bad public image and
now suddenly they're just getting the
gate you know the money it's a whole
different animal and now they were too
late with america yeah they could never
pick it up so they sold the company
actually the ufc bought pride fighting
championships and now they had all these
great fighters vandalist silva miracle
croco coming to the ufc and it made the
ufc even bigger so yeah they did a
really good job
i was surprised maybe i shouldn't be
that when i wanted youtube to look at
some of the full-length pancreas fights
that they were on the ufc official
channel so they must have bought the
catalog or the brand i was surprised but
then again
not surprised
you know
pride just for people who had never saw
pride
like you said it was
almost a video game with these matchups
right you'd have quentin
rampage jackson
howling with the chains around the neck
he could slam anybody imaginable didn't
matter and then he would have as you
mentioned bob sapp who became
gaijin tarento like this huge tv hit
he'd do like commercials for
hot dogs or whatever he became this huge
celebrity in japan
against some guy
half a size and on top of that you had
rules that were
just savage i mean you you had
van der ley silva soccer kicking
somebody in the head who's on his hands
and knees i'm just
absolutely terrifying
and
some of my favorite fighters of all time
like
kazushi sakuraba you mentioned a bunch
of other names
i mean just some incredible talents
and it's it just goes to show you know
there is there is planning and timing
involved and you know he who hesitates
is lost if when it comes to expanding
to the us do you have any other any
other fights or stories
any encounters interactions that really
stand out for you from
your involvement with pride
you know the one of the things that i
really always
enjoy is like mauro ronello my
commentating partner first of all
stephen cuadra was the fire professor
and then it became mauro ronello
he was very afraid of miracle croco
everybody was afraid of miracle croak
americo
said he would only want to be
interviewed by me
so a miracle is facing walt waterman
sorry to interrupt the boss could you
just
just paint a picture of miracle crocop
for people who didn't see him at that
time because it's something to behold
he's from croatia he's a special forces
do you see him guy rappelling down from
choppers and shooting people i mean this
guy's as legit as they come he came from
k1 which is the biggest kickboxing
organization on the planet knocking
people out with head kicks they would
say his left high kick i mean he knocked
people
i if you knocked 25 people out like that
i don't even exaggerating alongside a
kick to the body they would say left gig
body hospital left kick head morg that's
what they would say i mean and it would
always let they knew it would come but
somehow this guy was just a freaking
machine
and because of his special forces he was
very stoic
his answers if you interview him was yes
no boom boom he didn't want to be there
you know but with me he opened up me so
he was always sitting with me and then
he was facing one waterman one mottoman
is a pastor so he's the fighting person
he's a giant guy
so what i did i went to miracle
crocodile before and i said miracle i
want to pull the trick on marinello
because he's really afraid of you you
know i'm going to interview ron waterman
and i'm going to ask oh no because we
always i would interview one fighter and
then the opponent will be interviewed by
my commentating partner so one watermark
walks in and i immediately start
interviewing him
and maro didn't see it yet and as soon
as ron waterman leaves i say okay man
great and i go
and he goes what i go dude i'm sorry he
goes what do you mean
i interviewed ron
and he goes what do you mean okay you
you're gonna have to do a miracle he
said no no i don't want america i don't
want to interview america and i'm afraid
of me and i go you have to i can't
interview both fighters it's gonna look
weird for the people at home it's always
the perfect setup so the miracle comes
to the show and because he didn't want
to do interviews before it was
everything was on his time and he was so
powerful whatever he said they had to do
because otherwise he was looking to do
it
and he goes in there tomorrow and i'm
i'm with maro
and mirko start talking about yeah he
says oh you you were there last for the
last fight mauro says no that wasn't me
he said no that was you he said i didn't
like the way you were talking about me
and he goes no
no no it was you and he looked at his
friends and everybody goes no it's you
and maro is looking at me like boss help
me out here and i'm just standing still
i'm not saying anything right so he's
that's getting and he gets more and more
nervous and miracle marco really pushes
it on he's super serious suddenly morrow
he gets up and he walks out and
everybody's talking to him said no you
got to go back man he says i don't want
to do it he doesn't want to be he hates
me i don't i don't want to do this
anymore so he goes back again and mirko
and then suddenly miracle gets up and he
walks through and mauro runs away right
and so this is over
pretty freaking out and then suddenly i
say tomorrow it's okay and he stands
down he's waiting as miracle comes
walking and he has this stern look in
his face and he walks straight up
tomorrow and marcus
and then at the very end he started
laughing mirko and he high-fives
tomorrow he says we're just messing with
you dude and they actually became really
good friends and it's online we we we
posted this it's hilarious mirko croak
of punks mauro ronello it's hilarious
when she watched that video and then i
have another fun story which i thought
was hilarious i wanted to bring the
people at home on the bus tour b-a-s
instead of bus tour the bus tour and
they was going throughout all the
backstages at the fights we go to the
fighters that's the dressing room oh
here are the doctors let's see what they
test out all that kind of stuff right
so i'm walking i want to walk into the
doctor's office and i'm opening the door
and the first thing i see is all the
p-tests
from the fighters in little paper cups
with a little wooden thing on it
with the name on it and i'm right away i
re i have a great idea of course so i
close the door i go okay let's just wait
outside you guys let me ask the first if
it's okay we come in i mean it's a
little intrusive you know if we just
walk in right now can i let me talk to
the doctors and say if everything is
okay so i close the door i get one of
these cups i put green tea in it i put a
little lid on it and i put it in between
all all these other p tests from the
fighters
so now i'm walking in with the cameras
and i'm looking around and looking oh
there's the doctor okay that's why they
tested but
look here here's the b tests from the
fighters
man that's great right
wouldn't it be weird if you imagine by
tasting you could know which fighter it
is and they look at me like am i crazy i
said no serious i'm serious can you
imagine you taste the bee and you could
say that's that certain guy and he goes
you're crazy i said i'm going to try it
so i grab mine of course
with me
and i go and everybody's freaking out i
go
i can't go
i think this is mark coleman
these people were freaking out they were
thinking they thought i was drinking the
beef from mark coleman it was hilarious
until of course they found out i was
messing with them
those kind of things that's right up my
alley man messing with people
so i want to paint a picture for folks
who may not recognize these names so
mark coleman
certainly sort of pre and smashing
machine documentary era along with mark
kerr just monsters absolute monsters
right i mean
i remember
his solution for someone pulling guard
was just neck cranking them so hard that
their head might pop off and that was
the end of the match
and for people who don't know miracle
croakup they should look him up and
watch some video the guy's thighs were
as big around as my dinner table
and
not not only could he kick i remember he
fought just to tie two names together
that have come up he fought
bob sapp and he was so disdainful he was
i remember watching the translations of
course i don't speak croatian but
translated into japanese he's like i
hate people who win just because they're
big and he was so
it's just scornful of sap and he threw a
body kick planted the foot and then
hit him with a straight and i think he
crushed his eye orbit
with gloves on and i think from that
point forward bob sapp's eyes were
pointing in different directions i mean
it seemed like that was a real
turning point i mean just absolute
animal self worth worth checking out if
people haven't seen him bob samples you
know he
asked me one time if i would fight him
what i would use and i said i'll kick
your knees i'm not going to kick your
thighs because the carrying weight a lot
all day long and i go for the body i
said because your stamina is not that
good and i think with the body shot that
will work with you and then he fought
ernesto hoost and he who dropped him
twice with a body shot but then
he got lucky he swang so hard that
ernesto host on his defense and the the
scraping of the own glove gave a cut to
ernest hoost and he lost the fight
but then after the fight he had to face
miracle crocop and he came to me if i
wanted to train him
so i went 11 days or 12 days before the
fight because i was the accommodator i
went to japan to train with him
i trained him one and a half day
one and a half times
and the rest he was doing interviews
and i go
bob you understand that miracle crop cop
has a picture of you on the back and
you're the biggest guy right now he's
gonna annihilate you yeah but the people
want to see me on tv they don't care
about you you're gonna lose this fight
and you're not gonna beat me on tv you
need to focus on the fight wait with all
this stuff but apparently he thought
that was important and he kept doing it
and then yeah this happened against
miracle croco he wasn't just prepared he
was a gifted athlete bob sapp it's just
that he didn't take the time anymore to
prepare that was his problem
yeah got his skull crushed oh my god i
remember that wince that look because it
wasn't a knockout it was a different
facial expression and you just saw him
kind of crumple and i was like oh
god horrible
so for for people who may
i also just want to this is such a trip
down memory lane for me
i'm going to put some links to ramon
decker kobat who i actually met and
trained with a bit in new york city
because at least at the time that's
where he lived
i mean their fights repeated fights were
just
absolute brutality and then rob cayman
who wore if i remember correctly those
shorts was like a rainbow on the front
he was like a care bear
different times like you know the
murderous care bear
let me ask since we've covered a lot of
a fight game
for people who are wondering how
professional fighting
differs from say street defense i know
you've you've certainly spent a lot of
time bouncing you've had your fair share
of street fights outside of bouncing and
you've thought a lot about this and
you're you're a very highly qualified
former professional fighter right
because there are a lot of kind of
youtube black belts who
teach all sorts of nonsense
so how do you teach a self-defense
course to people who are let's just say
moderately athletic right so they're not
total couch potatoes but they're not
athletes they're not fighters how do you
how do you teach self-defense
you know you have to really break it
down you just don't want to start with
the basics it's footwork it's planting
your feet explaining where the power
comes from all that kind of stuff that's
why you really want to break it down
because i cannot teach you
to throw combinations in one or two
classes i can teach you to throw a
really hard freaking cross you know
because i will tell you where the power
comes from pushing off on the back foot
rotating your upper body so little steps
take here and there but the problem with
self-defense is what i said in the
beginning in my thai boxing i was more
the dojo fighter i was not developed yet
into a professional fighter so i didn't
have that control in the dojo i didn't
have that in my fights now luckily for
me i was just very powerful and just
slaughtered people and i won everything
by first round knockout one in the
second round the rest eight in the first
round so i was just strong
but again like i said if i would face a
good guy that would be a problem for me
so for people if you want to do you take
a good
self-defense class by the way
this nice i'm going to throw it in we
just shot a shot just we shot at the
beginning of covert when everything went
down the drain
seven skills to save your life with a
friend of mine amir perez
google his name on youtube amir perez
he'll take a gun away from somebody in
like two hundredths of a sec faster than
the brain can react you'll see things
that you you simply that's it's not
possible and he's doing it you know so
what you need is to make sure that you
can do it under pressure as well now
there's a lot of things that you can try
to mimic it with a lot of stress and
screaming like they do in the military
but still for a military guy as well if
you never shot in a live
person and the people are shooting back
at you with real bullets it's a whole
different animal you don't know what
you're going to do but as long as you
did it a lot and put you in worse
situations get you really tired of
screaming and punching slapping you in
the face and then suddenly you still
have to get your bearings together to
fight that will be really good doing a
self-defense class twice a week and
thinking you're going to win in a fight
well first of all
it's always better to know a little bit
than not you know if if both of you
don't know anything but you had like
five classes you have more chance it's
simply that's how it is you know because
you did it still five times you have
more chance is it still not it's of
course it's not enough but you have a
better chance plus if you do
self-defense
if you're in a situation a really bad
situation we will always tell you to
avoid the situation of course they want
money give them money
anything comply that's what you want to
do but if this guy is not wearing a mask
and you just shot somebody and you see
him well now you're going to be a
witness in court so the chances you're
going to die are really astronomical
high they don't want you to show for him
to kill one or two people it's almost
the same sentence so he's not going to
let you go so at that moment you're
going to be forced to do something
because if you don't you're going to die
now if you have a little bit of skill
then you increase your chances right
away with defending yourself but sure if
you had it did it three times or two
months even that it's not going to be
enough but still we had
we were teaching uh
law enforcement and
he was teaching a law enforcement
officer uh defending a knife and do a
counter attack and how to do that and
that guy called him back like six weeks
later sent him an email and he said that
yes she
saved my life i mean i knew instantly
what i was doing and i was just seeing
it one time but this guy was trained
already and he just came back with that
situation like kind of with me with the
heel hook that i did that i saw a day on
tv
he had that as well and it actually
worked for him and he over he overcame
the guy and it saved his life so you see
so it's all people who say yeah but it
will never work it's always good to know
i always say it's better to have a skill
and don't need it than to need a skill
and don't have it you know so it's
important that you do it and if you do
street fight self-defense
see if you can fight
amateur doesn't matter but do something
under pressure because i'm telling you
it's a whole different animal like my
first time boxing fight i i always tell
this story
i knocked him out with a back kick to
the body if at that moment when i
dropped him they would have blindfolded
me they would have called it four other
guys all with thai boxing shorts not
even the same thai boxing shorts and
they put them next to each other they
take the blindfold over they say who are
you fighting i don't think i could point
them out because you're not fighting a
person you're fighting a silhouette it's
really weird you don't hit the you don't
hit the jaw you don't hit the nose you
hit the
head
whatever you see you hit you know it's
uncontrolled you don't have it down yet
you need to you know it's like like
anything in life the more you do it you
better get you get at it so for a person
if you really want to be good at
self-defense
schedule a kickboxing match even if it's
amateur and it doesn't matter if you win
or lose people are so focused on the
winning of course it's fun to win but
just to for you to feel that pressure
you know to go there and then and you
don't want to do it they're going to be
moving to the dressing room that you're
going to go oh i'm doing it i want to go
i want to go and then still do it you
overcoming your fears that is something
i think is very important so that's why
we with the course that we have the
seven skills to save your life the first
is situational awareness we have like 45
minutes only on that now why don't you
walk out of the house in the morning and
you just stand there instead of walking
through your cars on your phone why
don't you look around
just make it a habit look around oh so
you see anything out of the ordinary
it's somebody in the car it's somebody
you know little things and we give them
all the hints why you have to focus on
you go into a bar you go into a
restaurant know where the fire escapes
are right away we make it the game with
the kids you know where's the fire
escape or at the toilet daddy oh there's
also one in the kitchen i saw you see
you start doing that and the kids start
picking it up and it's for fun but it's
it's the most important thing because
they say all this when you hear about
terrorists all that says 85 is
preventative measures you know 85
percent of all the attacks they already
stopped them before it happened that's
how important it is to have situational
awareness and then we go over into the
stance and then slowly but surely once
the stance is there we start building on
that stance and then you we give you a
few weapons we're not going to give you
spinning back kicks you're never going
to pull over i never pull off a spinning
back again a fight is the dumbest thing
to do because if you miss it you're in a
bad position just stuff that really
works focus on a few things knife
attacks well there's this knife attack
there's the under this is 80
that stab is coming up like a volleyball
yeah and f focus on those those are the
highest percentage possible they're
going to bring chances they're going to
use that it's the same on the street if
he's right-handed he's going to throw
straight bunks know the defense for that
and we break everything down and if you
do a very slowly and methodical and
grind it in over and over again and then
we have tricks to get you off balance to
get you very dizzy and then still you
have to act slowly but surely you learn
the fighting skills and once you have
that fighting skill that is the best to
go to a gym and to simply keep doing it
you know it's
you can't learn something once or twice
a week and then believe that you can do
it really don't think that it's not the
movies you know i'm always afraid that's
why i stopped actually teaching
self-defense in classes because people
come in and they get a false sense of
security like for instance if it just
teaches a knife defense and they're
walking on the street and suddenly his
his friend gets into trouble with
somebody and somebody pulls a knife and
he's going to go hey step back i got it
i just had this in class you see and
then he might die and that's kind of my
fault then you know especially if you
thought it the wrong way so
make sure that you do your homework that
krav maga worldwide that's an
organization they're very methodical
they're constantly updating the
curriculum and making it better you know
with things that happened in the field
you know for instance it was a gun
defense and there's a certain way to
wrap it out of the hand well it happened
one day it happened it saturated the
finger broke and it wrapped around the
trigger guard and they couldn't disarm
him boom immediately when that story
comes in then they adjust it and they
make sure that that can never happen
again was one time and maybe a hundred
thousand times but hey still you see but
they're constantly adapting and that's
what they do so krav maga k-r-a-v
dot com and if you do slash boss
b-a-s it will send you to a link and
then you can watch it we have some
videos there
and you can see how how we present it to
the people because it's important to
give you little bits and a little bit
more every time
you need to be 100 sure that you can
actually do that certain technique
so a few things i'd like to say and then
a question so the first is
one of my favorite quotes that i think
applies to just about anything is
from an a very old poet
writer arco locus and his quote is we do
not rise to the level of our hopes we
fall to the level of our training
and what you were describing just in
terms of psychological preparedness and
translating from training to
live
say competition or self-defense makes me
think of this example which always stuck
with me which was in college i was
competing in judo
after being in japan and
i remember at one point wandering by
this self-defense class for women which
was being taught it was it was being
taught maybe once or twice a week
and i went in to
offer to help i wanted to see if i could
just volunteer time to help and
the woman who was running the class said
no this is women only and it was women
practicing with women and i thought to
myself
my god if you're women practicing with
women and you think that men are just a
slightly
larger version of women it's like look
at the strength ex you have to feel the
strength differential and the aggression
differential
you take 130 pound women and 130 pound
man they are not the same and you if if
you have any hope of acting under
duress when it matters you have to
experience that or you're going to be 1
in 100 that you're going to possibly do
anything correctly and it really stuck
with me that um
need to practice let's talk about high
percentage
high percentage techniques you've spent
a lot of time bouncing so you get you
get a good amount of practice dealing
with
different types of aggression different
types of situations
and i'd like to ask you as a bouncer
two things so number one
if you
defused situations successfully or were
able to de-escalate them were there any
particular approaches or things you
would say that seemed to work for that
if you were training a week-long course
for bouncers right the de-escalation
moves or
expressions or questions or whatever you
might use and then when it really just
escalates and you need to take care of
somebody but you don't want to break
your hand or maybe get sued or
whatever it might be what do you do so
if you could just answer those two
that would be great
first of all it's taking the two people
who it starts with take them to the side
don't put it in the gym walk outside
with them do something that they feel
more comfortable and not with everybody
there like for instance what i would be
they really wanted me as a bouncer why
because i could fight no no that was not
the real reason the reason was it that
was came in handy i'm really good with
people from the ten situations nine
times we don't fight because i talk
about of it it's always and the only
thing that i would always use break down
the situation why they got into a fight
and you're going to find out it's always
stupid
like oh my god
yeah he was looking at my wife i go he
was looking at your wife yeah did you
talk to her no did he touch him no did
he say deregulatory things at all did he
make face to heart no no no no did he do
something against you so to to make you
mad no you didn't do that i go that's a
compliment dude i mean that means your
wife is a good looking wife he didn't
overstep he didn't do anything he didn't
touch her and he started looking and go
like yeah yeah i go come you come here
and then i would call the other guy i
said did you say something bad he says
no no i was just looking at his wife and
he got really angry you know that and
then they start seeing yeah this is
stupid because it's alcohol alcohol once
that's involved he makes stupid mistakes
and once they say okay shake hands you
guys want a drink and i would give him a
beer and the fight was solved so simply
breaking it down
but in a nice and calm way this is very
important because the screamers will
never work you get them on the toes no
fighting stats no nothing hands down and
and and once you talk to a person always
make sure you look at their hands either
this is the first thing i always tell
people if they put their hands in the
pocket or whatever always expect
something you know it's better to to be
a little bit
on your toes there maybe get a
handkerchief out it doesn't matter but
always look what they have in their
hands and as soon as they don't have
anything in their hands just take them
outside break the situation down and
they're gonna find out it's stupidity
what they're doing and then the fights
it's going to be off there's not going
to be a fight now if there's a fight and
it depends where it is you know if it's
in a bar like i put my back against the
wall if there's a corner i'm with my
back in the corner because nobody can
attack me from the sides now i got my
feel perfect view it's going to be very
hard to sneak up behind me you see so if
you have a wall great if you don't have
over the corner corner even better go
into the corner but it depends again on
the situation what's nice get present
and you need to get out maybe you don't
want to be in the corner you want to go
to the accident you want to get the heck
out of there don't fight if they have a
knife don't let your ego control
yourself you might die i mean people
do things for no freaking reason you
know simply watch out but that would be
the greatest thing if somebody pulls a
knife you know that's the street
fighting dvd that i made long time ago
the crazy one you know grab a box tool
get something that you can separate him
from he needs something in between it's
very hard if i just hold the bar stool
in between for him to come closer you
know it's also very important then you
know that if the fight goes outside yeah
now it's my domain because now i got
space and once there's space
if you start hitting me i won't even let
you hit me and most of the time that is
enough people gotta go [ __ ] if i cannot
even hit him because then i've talked to
them i said good i could have hit you
already i could have hit you alright i
could have hit you again i could have
all right i hit one time in front of his
face you want me to really do this now
let's stop dude i don't want to fight
you know if you say it i don't want to
fight act like you're a little bit
afraid know you're not but you do the
audience because most of the time it's
egos as well right if i say oh i'm going
to kick your ass now it's an ego thing
he wants to prove himself in front of
everybody who's watching no just
de-escalate by saying dude i don't want
to fight it's so stupid to fight i don't
you oh i could have hit you here already
and nine out of 10 times again
they they realize that you're the guy
with the skill and they're the guys with
no skill now sometimes when it's
absolutely not avoidable anymore yeah
well then you're going to have to go
fast and especially if there's a weapon
involved thankfully i did have those
situations many times because that's a
very bad situation and knife for
instance is a really bad almost worse
than a gun like a gun in front of me
i rather have that like when you stand
in my arms reach i rather have that than
when you have a knife a knife is much
more dangerous can cut from every side
especially if it's double bladed very
dangerous gun once you control the gun
in the barrel and you just go with it
and you make sure that you don't put
yourself in the line of fire you know
then everything is okay oh and by the
way gun defenses also make sure that a
loved one doesn't stand on the side
because if he pulls the trigger that
person is going to go so you have to
situational awareness that's all stuff
that you need to know and then it's
basic stuff like i said if it's without
a weapon if they're standing with the
left leg front they're orthodox that
means the right hand is gonna come
nobody's gonna throw a hook on the
street everybody's angry everybody loads
up that punch because they're angry you
see so all these things are easy they're
people have no clue how easy it is for a
professional fighter it's like me
challenging a a basket professional
basketball player to shoot some hoops
who you think is going to win right i
mean come on we do this every day single
day two three times a day you're not
gonna win it's not gonna happen yeah if
you maybe from the back hit us but
otherwise it's not it's simply not gonna
work
you know and if you can bring that over
to them and they realize that with on
top saying i don't want to fight you
know always say you don't want to fight
because that makes you feel good you
know that it's not a threat most of
times they stop and otherwise it's the
cross counter the cross comes they
always hit in an angle so that means
they always come from the side so the
only thing you have to do is literally
move backwards because then the point is
already going to miss you and there's
your counter it's a very simple counter
either a cross or if it's an elbow it
depends how close he is but if you learn
distance and that's the first thing we
focus on on your stance and on distance
because distance is everything because
if a person stands here this punch is
not very powerful it's better to go an
uppercut a hook or an elbow in this
distance just for people who are
listening right if somebody is a few
inches from your chest or like within a
foot of your chest yes what i say in
seminars the longer a strike travels the
more power it has the more time it has
to pick up speed and power and i always
use an example with a bow and arrow and
i grab the person in the in the room i
grab a bow and arrow i act like i have a
bow and arrow i said if i and i put my
hand against his chest if i let this
arrow go it's going to go in this deep
but if i step back three steps it's
going to go straight through him now i
gave it space and now it had time to
develop speed you see so that's also
like if people hit me on close distance
i bring my head closer to their punches
here it hurts but if i bring my head to
the hand he cannot load up anymore you
see i'm cutting off the distance these
little things are not going to do
anything but if i move away then he's
got reach in order to hit me hard so
distance is everything and especially
when you're backing up and somebody
comes at you
if he comes with aggressive power and
you make the defense but his face is
here you see now a punch is not good you
have to change it to an elbow so that's
why it's always good to have
some classes with people who break it
down like this just a few techniques
it's not that difficult to knock
somebody out but make sure that you
don't have too many techniques just a
few techniques and know them very well
and you're gonna be okay
yeah and i'll just say for folks
listening or watching and i mean this
will sound obvious
don't start fight you just do not know
who you're [ __ ] dealing with i
remember
when i first moved to san francisco i
was training at a at a muay thai gym
called fairtex at the time i don't even
know if it's there anymore and one of
one of the fighters
terrible temper he was pretty good he
wasn't great he wasn't professional but
he went out to a bar started a fight
didn't mind his back he wasn't in a
corner got stabbed right through the
lung
by someone who was behind him and then
one of the instructors
also alex gong
guy ran into his car
and then kept going
and alex's car was parked and the gym
had this garage door and he chased the
guy
and the car stopped at a red light and
he punched the guy's window in
and the guy had stolen the car pulled
out a gun just shot him in the chest and
that was the end of alex you just do not
know who you're dealing with so don't
i also have funnier stories like when my
uh
the guy i was training with at the time
n who was a world champion in thai
kickboxing but he was tiny tiny little
guy
he wore really loose clothing and he
went out to a bar and some guy started a
fight with him
and uh kicked him once and broke every
rib on one side and that was that was
the end of that so moral of the story if
you can avoid it
and emotions check them you know you
cannot get in you need controlled angle
like bruce lee said because anger like i
said makes you load up the punch you
know that's why you
that's why you want to get your opponent
angry in a fight in a professional fight
because if they're really angry they
start loading up they start telegraphing
you know it's very hard to control your
emotions but you control your emotions
you're going to win the fight
so i want to ask you
we're going to get to o2 trainer in a
second because i have one on my
table at home and i i want to ask a
number of questions about it before we
get there grand theft auto 4
all right so
how did you get involved with grand
theft auto and what the hell happened
there
oh they called me and they said if i
wanted to do the the motion cap actually
every fight you see and we made history
in that game so for that you know that
because all the video games are doing it
right now i came up with that because we
were doing the the
motion cap with all these little balls
on here you know and then you have to
hit and then they track the balls but i
said listen if you punch somebody and if
i hit the air you see me hitting the air
you know we need to hit something solid
he goes why i said it's going to look
much better i said i'll show you so i
gave him a crossword cross i showed a
few techniques i said go watch this i
called my buddy amir was holding the
focus mitts but for me the type hats
and i hear that and i remember they were
up there
looking at the footage and everybody
went yeah they started screaming because
now you see literally connecting and you
see the power coming back it made it
much more realistic so all the
the carjacking the fighting on the
street that you see we did that as well
but then the best thing came they wanted
me to have my own tv show
in the game so there's two 10-minute
episodes
of in the man's room with boss and
jeremy is a very funny show
dude i had to send people out of the
room because they start messing it up
every time because they started laughing
so hard i got a script and i started
breaking up the script i would mid
sentence i would act like that was a
period and then i restarted so it sounds
complete psychotic what i'm saying it's
like what is this guy talking it's
completely crazy you know once you start
shouting at the audience the fake
audience is there who wants the knife
fight with me in the audience you know
as a commentator as the host of the show
you see oh i love that stuff that was
the best work that's one of the best
works i ever did i think you know for
the people gta4 boss woodson go on
youtube they have the both the episodes
i think it's hilarious that's kind of
humor that i really like so
all right so we'll link to those in the
show notes
question this is gonna
well i don't think this is gonna be
difficult to cover at all but
i thought i would be remiss if i didn't
ask about the role of prayer in your
life yeah and i read about this and
i don't know if you still
pray the rosary every day
but
i'll read something that
i found in the research this was
on
catholicexchange.com i'll give them
credit here but
here's the line and you can correct me
if any of this has changed or is wrong
it just lets me focus it's meditating to
me as it is to many others take your
time to do it go to a quiet spot and
start when you really go over the
mysteries and those are in quotation
marks and visualize them and repeat the
prayers it will calm you down so could
you speak to i'm not
affiliated with any religion could you
please just describe the role of prayer
for you and then also
just
elaborate on what the mysteries are
because i don't know what that refers to
okay so
the rosary they say
i'm a very divided catholic it's at the
first hour of the day it's all prayers
that's what i start with it's also a
rosary i do a lot of reading about it
it's really got me back into
the person i really want to be when you
say the word religion nowadays people
can freak out but see it like this i got
in this confrontation with this 23 year
old in the dog park and he knew that i
was a christian that i
loved jesus when did this happen this
happened maybe
four months ago okay
and he wanted to push my buttons
because there was something going on in
the fight and where i gave my thoughts
and he gave his thoughts he thought he
was right i said well i've been only
doing it for 30 years and i've seen this
many times so i i think i'm right but
hey whatever and i think he he couldn't
get that so he needed to get back at me
for something and then suddenly he said
to me uh they were talking about the
fact that nowadays you have some states
where people parked the car outside the
supermarket they load it up for under a
thousand dollars and then they take off
and then by law you can't do anything
because it's not above a thousand
dollars and i said those people are bad
people they shouldn't be doing that he
set the wrong example and he said oh we
used to do that in
in california but he has five hundred
dollars so he would still till 500 and
his father stands right here like father
of the year award right i mean he's
telling you that he just would steal
under five hundred dollars i go this is
crazy
and then he says oh and by the way my
christian friends they were the worst
they stole the most so that was an
attack at me right so i go yeah they
were christians but they were not
practicing christians then and he goes
no no they go to they they go to the
church every week i go oh okay let's use
that analogy then so what you're saying
is that if you walk around in my gym
once a week you're a professional
fighter is that what you're saying
and he looks at me and go or do you
think maybe you're gonna have to take
some classes and learn about that and
then maybe live like a fighter no
drinking no this no that no that no
chasing women no you know you have to be
a fighter maybe you think that you see
and that is how i apply the fighting i
just want to be a good guy
that's what i want to do clean up my
life and i never did bad things like
really bad things i did people who got
it they deserved it at the moment but
still now
it's much easier for me to just walk
away and i don't need to test my skills
anymore and it completely changed my
life it made me a much better person and
once i did that i saw my whole family
started changing i didn't even ask them
now they started coming around because
they saw that the husband my wife and
the father changed you know i started
just becoming a much
better person think about what you say
you know look about truth look all these
kind of things so
then somebody told me that you know once
you do a rosary a rosary every beat that
you have of the rosary is kind of a
shotgun blast to the devil and
especially if you do it in latin oh wait
a minute latin yeah okay let's learn
everything in latin then you know if the
devil really hates that and if you
really start thinking because people
when you say devil and you say go
they say a lot of things you should do
really some homework and search for
people who had a near death experience
who actually went to hell or purgatory
for that matter you know there's some
really crazy stories that you hear and
it's like whoa it's right in your face
and it's all the same they all say
exactly the same story thousands and
thousands of people around the world so
i just started
wanting to become that person and now it
got me in such a thing listen i wake up
people are like oh my god you look great
oh it's probably using steroids you
always have these people talking like
well you can test me every day i'll take
any bet you can literally test me for
six months straight if you want a blood
test also another p test the blood test
every single day you can contest me and
if i look the same after cess month
let's put some money down because i'm
going to make a good amount of money
because i don't but if you live like i
do
then you might look like me as well i
wake up at 5 30. i do a prayer here
there i'm in the gym at six o'clock
first thing i do go to the trainer 30
repetition post it every single day for
the last four and a half years i post
every single day once i have a habit i
might have missed 60 times over four and
a half years you know because i just
once i create a habit that always helped
me also with fighting i just stayed with
the habit and it became more and more
and more relaxed and it was severe
because the more i learned about it the
more time i would took to learn a
certain prayer to do certain things the
more calm it got me and i just i just
feel really great right now i mean i'm
enjoying life i'm doing everything it's
like
i'm feeling really good and to go back
to the rosary in the rosary you have
five decades and they're every time
they're different on every day of the
week
so mondays and saturdays are the same
and the mysteries of mondays and
saturdays is the annunciation that's the
first 10 march you meditate about the
annunciation when gabriel came to mary
and say hey
you're going to be pregnant this is
going to happen
then the number two
the number two is that you go visit
elizabeth the zechariah you know because
john the baptist came from there and
that's number two then number three is
when jesus gets born number four is when
you present him in the temple and all
these little things if you read about it
you can visualize those situations while
you go over the beat so you're turning
off the world
and you focus on these mysteries it's
pure meditation you know you're
completely cut off and you folks are
sometimes well sometimes many times you
know you might start shooting all over
the place again you just gotta reform
again because it's a 15 minute thing or
if you do the latin it's like 90 minutes
it's a little longer you see but those
are the mysteries the very uh
boom boom boom at the very end is when
they lose jesus for three days and they
find him in the temple that is monday
and saturday on tuesdays and fridays are
the sorrowful mysteries this is where
the crucifixion with the with the
the
the crowding of thorns they're scorching
at the uh at the pillar all that stuff
all the bad things that happen on
tuesday and then you have wednesday and
sunday that's when he comes back this is
where he resurrected
and and then when he goes up to heaven
and he's talking to the 40 days and 40
nights and talking about everything
that is on
wednesday and friday and on thursday you
have the illuminous mysteries that's
what i do some people don't but then
and that's
you start with the baptism in the jordan
then the wedding at kana you know it's
all these things from the bible that you
focus on and once you start on every
beat you have a situation in your mind
how the story goes for you it's really
easy to just focus on that and to cut
off all
the noise in the in the outside world
like for instance we did twice
the exodus 90. that's that's like lent
on steroids right so it's for 90 days
you are not allowed to drink sweets no
sodas no you can't eat sweets get eat
only three times a day nothing in
between nothing you can't watch tv you
can't watch on your phone you can be on
your computer only for your work you get
you can listen to crazy music only music
that lifts us all you can only do cold
showers you have to work out every
single day and then once you start doing
that i realized my my social media
caught
with 80
because i realized i'm wasting so much
time on this stupid phone the whole time
and trying to get likes and posting
videos now i'm reading a book and now i
learned something about life you see so
it completely changed me i did that
twice now and that's really yeah it
puts life in perspective what is
necessary what's not necessary and if
you keep it very simple
trust me that's the way to go all the
stuff that you like i had a portion i
had this and that it's all gone it's all
material stuff nothing's gonna help us
to get up there with that what's going
to help us to get up there is to be a
good person help other people and that's
what i want to be so i don't go crazy
but people are screaming and i won't be
the guy who's quoting versus well if you
want i can but i won't you know because
that
scares people off they think this guy is
freaking crazy you know but if you
really take it to the heart and you
really try to just be a good person like
friends jesus says the two greatest
commandments let's say you're an atheist
forget about er equipment number one is
rich love god with all your might all
your heart all your soul forget about
that one number two three people like
you want to be treated those are the two
most important commandments in the world
you think if everybody underwear in the
world would treat everybody like they
wanted to be treated themselves we would
win in this mess right now we wouldn't
that's it and that's the only thing i'm
going after i want to just meet that guy
i want to help you i want to help you
and hopefully you help me and that makes
me feel good i'll be that guy so that's
my take
on being a catholic and and i'm i'm
enjoying it every day like like against
with how many times i started in may
2015 with my rosary and you go how many
times you missed
never
how do you all your readings never miss
the day you know i just built a habit
and i did it but that what i had in in
praying and in in meditation i used to
do that also in fighting once i tell
myself today i'm going to do 10 rounds
of the on the back after
after a workout i better do it because
if i do 9 rounds
i can't look at myself in the mirror i
see a failure i program my mind in such
a way that i'm a complete loser so i
never want to experience that feeling
again so i always do the ten months
whatever it takes i wake up in the
morning now like i said i'm six o'clock
i'm in the gym do i want it no but i
have a really bad arm which you will i
can pull it up i had four neck surgery
so i atrophied my whole arm and you see
a whole dent in here you see that the
whole muscle is good
my whole arm was like this so slowly
over 11 years it came back i did with
two pound curls i couldn't pull the
trigger from a gun
you know and now i do 15 pound kills
they go oh that's a lot i go
dude that's over 11 years
you know it's not a lot i do 45 with the
left arm and i do only 15 parts with
this arm but i do it you don't have to
do every time everything you like that's
the problem in this whole society right
now we feel we think that pleasure
is the same as being happy it's not you
know you're just feeding your pleasures
you know your advices give more more and
more and it becomes more and it controls
you and once it controls you now it's
advice you know the powerful man this is
what i always say
well i have a line i do these talks
public speaking talks what kind of man
you want to be
i want to be a man who can overcome his
weaknesses vices and imperfections
a man who is not a slave to his passions
and desires but a real man who's in
control of himself so i say oh i take a
drink oh i have another drink now you
have a little bit of bus you really want
the third one no because that's gonna
set me over the edge i'm not gonna do it
that's a powerful guy to say no to
advice all these guys who
who have sex all day long and drinking
and drugs and profanity are screaming
all the time those are the most insecure
weak people of the planet we think we
believe they are the strong people but
they're the opposite because they can't
control devices they're a slave to their
vices they can't say no to alcohol once
i read because i was an alcoholic well
you got to say i am right because
apparently it's never go away but once i
read
that i was a slave that alcohol was
telling me what to control my life that
was it i didn't drink anymore when did i
have i did my whole life and once i read
it in the bible somehow boom it clicked
and i stopped doing it so if all these
great things are coming to me and it's
really helping me i see it as a very
positive thing and i truly believe that
everybody would live like i live
we would have been a very happy world i
truly believe that do i have my fight
listen we all make mistakes i make
mistakes but all the mistakes i make now
i do to myself are little tiny things it
will never be a judging thing like a
complete douche uh walking around
screaming at people you know that you
you almost want to say in the past i
would say something now just shut up now
if he does something bad like hits a
woman or whatever oh trust me that's the
thing right you can jump in right away
the they don't say turn the other cheek
that's jesus we don't do that we help
the people i like to see myself as a
sheepdog you got wolves you get sheep
and you get the sheep dogs to protect
the sheep from the wolves and i like to
be that guy i like to be a powerful guy
who can control his emotions and his
vices and once i can do that i just feel
really good about myself
there are a bunch of questions that come
to mind i want to go to the the workout
and the o2 trainer and also what you do
after that but looking at you now for
those people who aren't watching video
or just listening to audio i mean you
seem like despite the surgeries
and the atrophy of the right arm i mean
you seem like a very fit guy still to
this day and so what i was thinking as
you were talking about the dog park is
who on earth thinks it is a good idea
to
get into some type of altercation with
boss root and
how did that start
him and his father also and his father
told me the next day he says boss he's
doing that all day long to me i mean
he's pushing the budget they've been
never
like i have students and when you see
them they look like this
don't piss them off
you're gonna lose this you know and
with me he did that if he would have
done that 10 years ago i might have
grabbed him by the throat because i
wasn't that fat i would have said now
you're going to stop would i've hit him
no probably not if he takes a swing at
me sure but otherwise but at least i
would've grabbed him by the throat he's
going to stop that right now but i
didn't do that you see so
it's it's just a guy who knows
that
probably that if i would hit him hey
that's a lawsuit right and they just
don't care but guys like that i told him
that i said you have to watch out
because you are gonna say this if you
say this to one of my 17 year old
students
he'll mess you up you're not gonna even
win this and he's five years younger
than you or six years younger than you
you see so i don't know what's wrong
with some people that's the same one as
alcohol well the alcohol challenges all
that that stopped after my whole crazy
sweden bar fight story with the five
bouncers and that was the whole
nightmare and
uh after people read that story nobody
ever challenged me again on the streets
and that was in 2001 i think in 2000 so
that thankfully helped but because
before that people were drunk and would
come up to me and i would just call to
the bouncers i said can you come here i
can take him out and they will get so
angry and i would write my name and the
phone number on the business card i say
here tomorrow morning call me and then
we will fight any rules you want we're
gonna fight but i guarantee you you're
not gonna call oh i'm gonna call you
don't worry you're not gonna call you'll
be the first one and then of course they
never go because they wake up and
they're sober and they go like yeah that
was really stupid you see so
just it makes me more calm
so we can't tease the sweden story
without
oh
okay okay so sweden what happened in
sweden oh okay so there was crazy boss
but understand this when i'm drunk i'm a
happy drunk i'm always drunky partying
and you know but still it's stupid you
know you because i don't have an alcohol
under control but still i was always a
happy guy when i walked into the bar
it's called the spy bar very notorious
for their bouncers being really bad
bounces i mean the whole sweden they
love me after this happened
so when i walked in they recognized me
and they said and you could keep it
quiet today boss and i thought that's a
weird thing to say why wouldn't i i
never get in trouble i get friends with
everybody
so i'm walking around dancing around and
this one guy wants to give me a drink
and suddenly a bouncer comes to me and
he says you have to go he says what do
you mean it says you're bothering the
customers i say who him i say he's
buying a drink for me right now so i
don't think i'm bothering can you ask
him no you have to come with us i said
dude i'm not bothering anybody so they
grab me i don't want to fight because i
know if i push somebody it's already
going to fight but i don't want to fight
so i walked with them and now with the
two bouncers we're at the fire escapes
and there's this big marble stairs going
down
and this guy is a little guy and a big
guy behind him and the little guy's
wearing a leather jacket i remember that
and there's this big guy stand croatian
guys croatia mob they said
and
i'm talking to the guy and he's he's
pointing on my chest the whole time and
i say guys i'm going don't worry about
it i don't want any trouble can you tell
my buddy he's also bald he's from
holland then i'm outside because
otherwise he has no clue where i am he
says you don't understand he's pushing
on my chest again it does there's no
there's no reason to touch me let's
let's not do that so then he touched me
again i pushed him away i said don't
don't touch me stop touching me and
right away the guy behind him the tall
guy stabs a finger in my eye so i'm
going like guys i don't want any trouble
and he takes my other eye
as soon as that happens i knock him out
because what's next he's going to kick
the ball he's going he's going to
escalate i mean once you take two eyes
so i knocked him out the problem was
they had these little microphones so now
three other parts has come in
and that guy of course he's out but
while i'm fighting the other bounces he
starts waking up so i'm dropping left or
right i put three in the hospital and
finally i had to go i realized
eventually i'm going to run out of gas
this is going to go wrong i got to go
down and this is a fire escape so i need
to go down so i'm running down i'm going
down while i'm fighting and i'm hitting
a hitting hitting and i'm going down and
i remember i still was there i remember
exactly how it looked that was one of
those copper things that you push in to
open the door and it was locked
yeah i couldn't get out but till that
time i was still fighting by the rules i
wasn't stabbing eyes i didn't kick the
balls i didn't all i was still kind of
just fighting you know not to destruct
so now i made up my mind and i turned
around and i told myself
i'm going to do any i'm going to stab
eyes i'm going to go all the way and as
soon as i looked at them they all
stepped back and i felt really powerful
for about
five seconds because i thought they saw
in my face that i meant business but it
wasn't behind me it was the whole police
force was standing behind me because
they had a hole
and that's why they stopped fighting but
they threw me in jail
from jail i went to a jail in a freaking
mountain you can google this i mean i
thought am i did i make this up no in
the mountain we drive in the tunnel the
tunnel stops in the middle of a mountain
i have to go to an elevator two floors
up go out three floors up go out four go
down go i go like this like a movie i
gotta come out of it you're like a bad
wizard in harry potter he was in spain
and then he put me in prison i still
couldn't call my wife
oh and this is always say my wife hates
this story but she kind of thinks it's
funny on one side or so but it wasn't
funny at the time
when i talked to her when i before i
went into the bar
she says why are you so happy i said
honey i'm just drunk
and i'm just having a good time she says
no no you're there with two swedish
blonde girls aren't you i go you know me
honey for me right now alcohol counts
that's my only folks okay i gotta go so
then two days she didn't hear anything
from me and now i call her and by the
way they wouldn't give me my first phone
call it was the guards who knew me who
gave me their cell phone and i was
allowed to call dude they gave me a tv i
had a vcr they gave me cookies t i was
playing cards with the guard it was
hilarious but but still it was not fun
because i was in jail and they told me i
was going to be six and nine months in
jail because apparently one of the cops
of one of the bosses was a cop
but you didn't say he was a cop so well
if you attacked me well yeah i'd knock
you out as well you said the cop of one
of the bouncers like the father of one
of the bouncers or the brother one of
the bouncers no no no one of the
bouncers was a cop off duty cop oh
apparently in sweden you need one law
enforcement person to be there as well
but he got the same treatment because if
he attacks me i got him
so i called my wife and she's freaking
out now and i go honey come i don't have
a lot of time i have some good and some
bad news and what do you want to hear
first and she says the good news i say i
didn't have sex with two swedish girls
because what the bad news is i'm in jail
he goes you think that's funny
[Laughter]
so thankfully i had some good guys there
who are pretty powerful guys who
convinced
the bad people to take the charges back
but otherwise i would have been there
six to nine months that's what they
wanted to give me for no reason then we
find out you can google this they put
people in jail for four years for
nothing there was a guy who went on one
of those guys
for the boxes he went on a big show like
an oprah kind of show in sweden and he
was crying on the show they sent it to
me and they he said that they put an
actress in jail for four years and she
didn't do what they said they were
their boss told them to do these things
he felt so bad because they were the
mafia bouncers that's what they called
them dude they put on the in the swedish
post they put a picture of my street a
self-defense dvd
and then below it said that one of the
bouncers said
we were so happy the police came because
we couldn't handle him my salesman threw
the roof over in sweden and i became
their hero because everybody had trouble
in that bar and now they finally had
somebody who would give it back you know
but still it was embarrassing now i'm
here and i can talk about it with a
smile but with the left but at that time
you know if you if you think you're
going to be there for six or nine months
for something you didn't do you know try
to convince it's five against one you
know nobody's going to believe me
so uh yeah yeah that was the swedish
story
prior lifetime
so the o2 trainer
this caught my attention i know this is
something that you're deeply involved
with
and i grew up with all sorts of
respiratory issues and i'm about to
spend time at high altitude in a few
months
so i was very
intrigued and went on amazon and was
quite blown away by some of the
testimonials in the
reviews and
i always as you might imagine i've had
hundreds and hundreds of guests
and there's always part of me that's
worried that their book is going to be
terrible or their movie is going to be
terrible or if
their product's going to be terrible but
the the reviews are really
outstanding and a bunch of my team
looked at it as well
what is the o2 trainer
who uses it what do they use it for how
do you use it
okay it's an inspiratory muscle trainer
let me let me this is the best way to
get in people's heads because once you
you know as well as i do once you start
talking about breathing people going
i've been doing them my whole life what
people don't realize is that they
breathe wrong i'll go into that they'll
give me a few facts these facts that i'm
going to give you are scientifically
proven clinically proven in published
medical journals you can look this all
up 100 to it
first of all there's nothing more
important in your body that you can
control
than breathing
it's the number one priority the
survival rule of three states that the
average human being can go three weeks
without food three days without water
three minutes without oxygen so if you
don't have oxygen for three minutes you
might die so that's the number one
priority in the world
your lungs fact number two 100 your
lungs don't do anything by themselves
your lungs are just two backs there's
not a muscle in your lung
the only way for your lungs to open up
is by chest expansion and when you
expand your chest you create a vacuum
between the body and the lungs that will
rip open those lungs so if you really
think about it your chest doesn't expand
because you put air in them your chest
expands and that's how you pull the air
in them
now the biggest mover for expanding your
chest is the diaphragm
and that together with the external
intercostal muscles which are the
muscles in between your ribs open up
your chest exhaling is done by your
obliques your abs and your internal
intercostal muscles and by the way just
that you know the average human being
has about 11 pounds of breathing muscles
fact number three metaboreflex do you
know what it is metaboreflex
i don't okay we know it as gassing you
know what gassing what happens when
you're gassing
when you let's say you're cycling and
you're going uphill suddenly you start
guessing that is your body regulating
got it getting really tired getting
really tired because it's going to pull
the air of your oxygenated blood it
pulls it away from your legs and it
sends it to your number one priority in
the body which are your breathing
muscles that's why you're gassing
because your breathing muscles are not
updated now let's attach another thing
to it stamina
how does it how is it why is it that
when you train really hard your stamina
increases there's got to be a real
reason for that well the reason is that
if you train a muscle over and over
again it becomes more efficient
and once the world already says it
efficient it uses less oxygen so boop
your stamina increases and now you're
going to go wait a minute so if i train
my eleven pilots or breathing muscles
they don't have to steal blood anymore
by the way stealing blood blood stealing
is a medical turn in gassing in a
metaboliflex
number five the fact this is the biggest
one and it's going to get everybody and
i'm going to get you with it as well tim
95 of us breathe from
so tim take a deep breath
you know he's raising his shoulders
that's a complete incorrect breath
the densest most rich part of your lungs
is at the bottom of your lungs and i
will go in a little bit over why we are
breathing wrong chest breathing four to
six of these breaths is the same as one
diaphragmatic breath or horizontal
breath think about that so if you're a
fighter and you come back out of a hard
round you go back to your corner instead
of raising your shoulder 40 times you
know i take the lowest number now
because it could be four to six you can
do the same amount of aircraft by doing
it ten times correctly and also think
about this you doing this your traps
your shoulders your neck muscles all
have to work they all cost oxygen
so why not updating your 11 pounds of
breathing muscles that you have so they
don't have to steal the blood anymore
about a bing bada boom you're going to
be good now
tests also show
that after the age of 29 you see what i
always
dislike when the project comes out and
they say oh this product will increase
your lung volume it's a lie you have a
set pair of locks when you're an adult a
guy is like one and a half gallon 6.4
liters i believe and a woman is 4.2
liters which give or take a gallon right
that's it you have it but after the age
of 29 your thoracic flexibility which
means your chest flexibility starts
decreasing and i already said it if you
need that to open up yeah that means
your lungs start shrinking they're
actually getting smaller after the age
of 29 so if you are a person who's 40
years of age and you never did any
breath work your lungs are smaller then
yes the auto trainer can make your lungs
bigger again but not bigger than they
were they just go back to the original
size that they had in the first place so
that is everything taught about
breathing the most facts 100 true
effects i always wrap it up at this
imagine you have two brothers right two
clones
identical in every way the fingerprints
if one gets caught for for murder
they're gonna have to figure out because
both they can be it you know if they'll
have dna that's how close they are they
eat the same drink the same sleep the
same they do everything the same and
both guys decided to do a triathlon and
then see who's the strongest from the
two of them
now they do the same things every
everything is the same so if a running
coach comes in he sits in front of them
they get the same information at the
same time from the running coach the
cycling coach at the swimming coach
now the one thing that
one does different is that he trains his
breathing muscles so his chest can
expand maximally and he can excrete also
all the air so he can move more air in
and out of his body who do you think is
going to win when they do the triathlon
now and everybody's going you know the
answer is the person who did the
breathing muscles this is how important
it is to train your breathing muscles
and you are breathing correct till
you're five and a half years of age you
can look this up go google it and you'll
see the studies that are there and the
reason is at five and a half hey that's
the age when you start going to school
that's the age when you maybe get belts
starbursts so now already your belly
bath gets away if you look at the baby
it breathes the belly like this we are
all chest beat we are actually the only
animal on the planet who breeds
incorrect every animal with a lung
breathe diaphragmatic breath that's what
they do so it's important that you make
sure that you focus on that technique
and the o2 trainer with heart resistance
is like a short resistance cap here when
you breathe in with resistance you
cannot pull the air in you're raising
your shoulders you're going to be forced
to use your core and once just that by
itself can give you up to five times
more oxygen in your body now with kids
also they become self-conscious for
instance they start seeing superman
superheroes they start seeing and girls
see barbie dolls and oh everybody needs
and if you breathe through your belly oh
other kids might think you're fat or you
go to the doctor and they put a
stethoscope and they say take a deep
breath i go
and then you think oh so this is where
my lungs are no that's not where your
lungs are your lungs are here that's the
most rich densest oxygen-rich part of
your lungs it's below so once you start
breathing the correct way what it did
for me if i have a fight that i show on
my website but i fought for ducky and
you see me in the corner like this
i'm chest breathing that is completely
gone i can go as hard as i want on the
round out of the back i come out this
dead
there's no movement let's think about a
military guy snipers and all the special
force you think when they're with a gun
they're standing do you think the chest
breathing of course not
belly breathing because there's no
movement here everything in your life
becomes better it's good it's for asthma
copd cystic fibrosis anxiety ptsd i have
a list on my website o2trainer.com
go there click on science there's a list
of published medical journals what it
does for you it will blow you away
publish medical journals for the people
at home i just want to touch on that it
means it's clinically proven to do what
it says i'm saying this because a lot of
people sell a product and it says it's
clinically tested stay far away from
that product it's just a way for them to
put the word clinically in and then some
people go oh clinically it's got to be
good no it's clinically tested what is
the result from that test that's what
you should ask because if it was
clinically proven it would have said
clinically proven so don't buy a product
if it says clinically tested because you
want to know what it did what the
results was now i brought this thing and
i wanted to do this really fast it's a
it's a vegetable steamer but guess what
it also looks like a diaphragm believe
it or not
don't shade tendon muscle
that's attached to the bottom part of
your ribs so if you want your fingers
down here and you stir them all the way
back along the spine now the bottom of
this
is is connected to the bottom of your
ribs and when you breathe in this
happens your diaphragm drops down and
from that view not a lot happened but
watch what happens from this fuel poof
it expands
so once this expansion happens inside
expand your chest and again there's the
vacuum between the body and the lungs
that'll open up your lungs and that's
how you breathe so the more chest
expansion you have the easier it will be
for you to fill up your logs where there
to me this is the gift that keeps on
giving i started training with the
prototype three weeks later and i told
you before i had severe asthma every
single fight everywhere i went to the
world i was always carrying an inhaler
with me because if i sneeze violently i
have my lungs closed have to open them
up many asper patients right now who are
watching have exactly the same that i
have
after three weeks i never even had an
inhaler anymore i don't have it i sent
it to my buddy in holland he's selling
he has asthma eight days later he calls
me he said dude i asked my husband so he
sells him in europe right now this is my
thing for the people at home
if you buy an o2 trainer for your asthma
or for your copd and it's not 70 or more
gone in one month and you only have to
do this for four minutes a day think
about that four minutes a day then i
give you your money back the only thing
that i want to see is i want to see you
doing the 30 repetitions because
everybody nowadays they say oh i did it
30 times you didn't you did it because
it's a workout you're going to feel your
core i have body builders buying it now
for their abs that's how much you're
going to strain on your abs and on your
back breathing muscles back breathing
muscles yeah you have muscles 360
degrees circumferential around around
your body they have breathe everywhere
once you start including your back
bleeding muscles and we have great
exercises for that on the website
and by the way if you do the back
breathing exercise do 15 repetitions we
tell you to do 30 don't do 30 you're
gonna walk around for three days in
enormous pain because it feels like
you've worked out your back muscles
really freaking hard so just do 15
repetitions these are muscles you've
never used before and you watch your
stamina go up it's just bizarre i had
leota machida you know lyoda machida as
well of course the ufc light heavyweight
champion he left me a message i can let
you listen to the message even if you
want
i gave it to him and he's a karateka guy
so that means
he's got habits i gave it to him i said
this is really good for you leoto he
started using it for four or five months
he got covered then he had coveted five
days after he had covered he decided to
start trading with his students again
who are fighting and competing in the
ufc and embellitor he says boss i
outworked everybody
i'd never been in control with my
breathing like i was there it's the most
insane thing he says my muscles got
tired but my breathing was completely
controlled he was blown away but he's a
guy who actually did it now the problem
at which i found out now two weeks ago i
woke up in the middle of the night ago
now i know why people stop using it if
you buy it for your stamina what happens
is this you're working out your
breathing muscles so right after you did
30 repetitions you have to do it a
certain way you can find it on online
you worked out your breathing muscles so
they're tired so then if you start doing
stamina yes it looks like it actually
works against you because you get more
tired because your breathing muscles are
tired the trick is to simply do it
anyway for 30 days straight because once
you update these muscles
i do sky is the limit they found out now
in preliminary tests that your second
wind is your diaphragm being warmed up
like i've been doing four and a half
years every day i just told you that if
i do a conditioning workout i do 30
repetitions and then i start hitting the
back and i have no dip i fly through the
workout every single workout that i do
stamina i'm like in the break i'm like
this is insane it blows me away till
this day every single time
and in the early days i was
i couldn't catch my breath it's
completely gone everything is controlled
right now and sleep apnea balance
back problems i mean look at the list
you have no clue you know that your
diaphragm is the main muscle for balance
you notice the diaphragm also massages
your intestines you know the diaphragm
also aligns your spine i mean
diaphragmatic breathing does things for
you you don't even know and it's only
four minutes a day i'm an overachiever i
do it five minutes today that's it five
minutes and then i started working
done
so question for you i'm gonna try it
i've had issues with endurance and
breathing my entire life so i'm actually
gonna give it a shot
and
how do you suggest when someone is just
getting started that they incorporate
this into their workouts so for me right
now i'll give you an example i'm going
on a high altitude trip i'm going to be
carrying a lot of weight
in
six to eight weeks
and my training right now is
let's call two three days of weight
training
a lot of rucking so carrying weight and
hiking marching
and then a handful of other things
and
i'm just curious how if you or me just
getting started probably have very weak
breathing muscles yeah how would you
incorporate it into your
week let's just say or your workouts
in the beginning i started doing my
workouts with it but then i got in
contact with the guy who used to train
usain bolt as well and use he says boss
stop doing the workouts with it i said
what do you mean i have a breathing
exercise for you and that's what you
should do like you say paul sleeps in a
in a high altitude tent he wakes up
first and when he comes out he does 30
repetitions inspiratory muscle training
he says that will do way more for you
then when i started doing that because
all this knowledge that i have about
breeding people i had a doctor tell me a
pulmonologist said dude you know more
about breathing than any doctor i know
not a pulmonologist but other doctors
it's insane i said well that's dr belisa
vranic you know she's a world renowned
breeding expert
and i'll tell you a fun story hopefully
we can touch on that right after this
but so what you start with is doing
breathing exercises it's very simple for
the basic thing normally you have to do
it with movement for now i would simply
put it in your mouth exhale squeeze guys
you want to squeeze all the air out of
your lungs i always explain it like this
imagine you have two buckets one bucket
is filled with bad water and the other
one is fresh water if i throw the bucket
with bad water if i throw 70 percent out
i can only fill it up with 70 good water
because there's still 30 left that water
in there so squeezing exhaling is very
important get all the bad air out so to
say the carbon dioxide everything that
you breathe out so you can use your
entire inspiratory system again to
breathe out
to inhale and to work this all these
muscles
in the beginning what you want to do you
want to grab the bottom of your chair
so you cannot raise your shoulders
whatever you do do not raise your
shoulders in the beginning also you're
going to get neck pain because if you
breathe in with resistance this is what
you're going to do in the beginning
you're going to clench your neck on your
face
and that's going to create muscle but
once you get the technique down
you just start breathing and breathe
pushing out your belly
focus on that once you get your belly
down and you really want to do this for
months then we're going to start
focusing to the bottom part of your ribs
because officially you want to do it a
little higher because that's where the
diaphragm is attached to but this is
what it would look like for the super
beginner
you sit
just focus on that those are your front
breathing muscles the back breathing
muscles like i said don't do 30 that
would be from the side it would look
like this you and your legs are like in
the 90 degree angle i'm just going to
lean on my legs and for now just sit
there don't do the exercise like i'm
showing you make it simple you're just
going to sit auto trainer breathe out
then you start breathing in and you
focus on the lower part of your ribs on
your back to expand and it's really
clear with how your mind works you will
feel this immediately just focus on
those muscles and you just relax every
muscle in the body
and only let your back muscles expand
you do only 30 repetitions of that and
that's it what i personally do i
alternate so today i do 30 repetitions
with the front breathing and tomorrow so
my front breathing muscles can rest i
attack the back breathing muscles
and then i flip every time so every time
i give the muscles that i take the day
before rest and i take the other side
so let me hop in for just a quick second
so for me then starting off
i would instead of doing it in my
workouts maybe i do it first thing in
the morning and i would alternate since
i'm just getting started 30 front and
then the next day doing 15 back
repetitions and not 30 because i'll feel
like i got
kidney punched by uh
by you
maybe if i overdo it
and i also say just for people who are
listening to just the audio and they're
like okay i think i hear darth vader
we will post this video of course on
youtube on my youtube channel for people
to see and i'm sure there are other
videos that people can find on
the o2 trainer youtube
channel and elsewhere so we'll include
all those links in the show notes but
for me just to be clear so if i have my
normal workouts maybe later in the
morning or in the afternoon sometimes
both
i would potentially do this say first
thing in the morning and do 30 front
then next day 15 repetitions back and
alternate back and forth two questions
is it seven days a week
do you recommend that to begin and then
second question is do you pause at all
between the inhales and the exhales
what i do is this as soon as i inhale
i swallow because if you don't swallow
and later on you're going to do the
exercise with movement you might start
drooling through the auto trainer now i
don't care but if you're somewhere
public and you want to do it you know
when you start drooling that doesn't
look that good
[Applause]
and then you're doing it
the 15 repetitions the first time you
did 15 the next day you do the 30 front
then when you go back to the back to 20
then you go back to the front then 25 so
every time just add five till you also
do 30 with the back breathing
that's the only thing for you i would do
and by the way tim if you go on the
website you click on science there is a
high altitude link from inspiratory
muscle training that will show you that
you can move more air in and out so it
helped you tremendously with i saw that
i actually clicked on it as you were
talking
yeah there's a study on pubmed
inspiratory muscle training altitude and
arterial oxygen desaturation a
preliminary investigation so you do have
some great links
on this site that i'm going to go
through later
these are these links i mean if you go
on a published medical journal website
and you put inspiratory muscle training
in the search bar click you'll have
hundreds
hundreds of published medical journals
you pick them and they will all say the
same thing the the story that i wanted
to say with dr belisavrenis right so
she's a world-renowned breeding expert
all my knowledge i have from her she
brought me to this rigorous course the
first time i met her she joey diaz the
comedian he actually set us up because
he said she's breeding you doing the
breeding exercise you got to meet this
lady how does sorry hold on how the hell
does joy diaz
know her how did that come about he can
roll whole classes now in brazilian jiu
jitsu he calls me every six weeks boss
loves you gotta go he loves it because
he said but since i've used the auto
trainer i can complete my brazilian jiu
jitsu classes which you could never do
before amazing all right good for him
but anyway we're at the office at fifth
avenue she grabs a measurement
she's going to measure my chest
expansion so i knew what she was doing
right away so she says exhale inhale and
she measures and she says inhale and she
goes and she started laughing she goes
she says no no that's not possible do it
again so i do it again and she looks at
me and says wait and she walks out and
she comes back with another doctor and i
go okay what's going on he says well if
i don't bring him he's not going to
believe it i said what's going on she
says well normally when people break our
chest expansion the difference between
inhaling and exhaling it's by an eighth
of an inch you almost went two inch more
than everybody else i had a breathing iq
you can go to the thebreathingiq.com
this will tell you how you have to
measure yourself thebreedingiq.com
number 100 is a great breath i had 182.
so it was a whole big difference and
then she realized it was this thing
and then she put it in a book
and that's when everything started
getting better
so yeah and and for the people who are
really interested and want to dive into
breathing we came out this week
breathing4warriors.com
go there it's everything you need to do
because what i'm saying now is the tip
of the iceberg but once you watch that
and you see what you can do with
breathing she gets you into some
breathing exercises that gets you high
without drugs you start tinkling like
crazy it's like people it's it's really
crazy what you can do and if you really
think about it also if you what is you
want to
meditate right meditation think about it
why do you think in aramaic in latin and
in in the hebrew language the word
breath is the same
as spirit spirit and breath are the same
words but it's all because it has a
connection so if you want to meditate
get your breathing in in a perfect form
because once that happens
i mean sky is the limit you can take up
to five times more oxygen people have no
clue we all think oh i've been breathing
since i came out of the room you're
breathing wrong if i was breathing wrong
fighting professional fights
chances are you are too and those five
percent who are breeding correct
probably have breathing classes that's
the difference
this is exciting to me i'm gonna i'm
gonna try this out because as you noted
i mean there's a lot of
nonsense out there there's a lot of
hand-wavy pseudo-scientific
[ __ ] frankly but as you noted i'm
just searching on pubmed.gov
for
published research or
at least research that's available on
pubmed i just put in
inspiratory or inspiratory i'm not sure
how to pronounce that word honestly
muscle training and their 2032 results
the first result is
inspiratory muscle training for asthma
and it just goes on and on and on i mean
there's there's to enhance recovery from
mechanical ventilation
functional capacity in patients
undergoing cardiac surgery it goes on
and on so there's a lot of
published literature that one can lean
on and it makes
logical sense when you
lay out as you did sort of the
functional anatomy and the process for
proper
or any respiration
really it's always struck me as odd i'm
glad you mentioned it when somebody's
like improve your lung capacity i'm like
is that even possible i mean it seems
like
yeah
but it does make sense that if at a
certain point past age 29 or whatever it
is when you start to
atrophy and lose the ability to
muscularly
expand the chest to create the vacuum to
therefore
then lead to filling the lungs
that you would
exhibit all the negative effects
of that so i'll give this a go i'll let
you know how it goes
beautiful
what should one expect
of course your mileage may vary people
are different and i'm sure you have high
responders and you have maybe lower
responders
but
what would you suggest
not so that it's pie in the sky
expectation and people are potentially
disappointed but
just a cons maybe a conservative
expectation that someone could have
let's say me
after
30 days of doing this because i will
have basically 30 days until i need to
be at high altitude and kind of
performing because i'll be
i'll have a lot of weight on my back and
i'll be moving up steep inclines at
altitude at you know eight to nine
thousand feet so let's call you know
3000 meters
after 30 days what would you expect that
i might experience or see
well the thing is that you you
automatically start breathing correct i
had a swat guy a swat officer who said
he used the autotrader today the next
day he was running and he broke his
running time and he says that's
impossible he says he said but boss then
i started thinking about it i was
breathing wrong and the auto trader
forced him to use his core and the next
day when he was running he was using his
core therefore he got more oxygen in it
that's over one day you do this for 30
days you program your mind especially if
you do it early in the morning it's like
the book reading the the world's
greatest salesman right you have to read
that three times a day it takes 10
months to read i did that you know
because once you do that in the morning
first thing in the morning in the middle
and then before you go to sleep you
realize for 30 days within 12 days you
memorize the whole thing you can it's
crazy you ingrain it in the mind and
it's the same thing here with your
muscles you do it the first thing when
you get up if you really want to take it
to the next level do it in the evening
as well if you do it twice a day and
especially for a big trip like you're
going to do tim you want to do both same
exercise on one day because then the the
the front breathing if you try to take
it twice they can rest the next day when
you attack the back muscles twice you
see what i mean because otherwise it's
like triceps every day eventually their
bear shape is going to stop because they
need rest in order to get stronger right
rest and protein that's what they need
that's the same with the breathing
muscles you're going to feel it
immediately then especially if you do it
for 30 i always want to say if you're
professional fighter
like every fighter is jealous of tony
ferguson tony ferguson why are they
jealous of him because he's the guy with
the unlimited stamina now watch tony go
back to the corner
sit there watch other fighters
watch tony
there's no movement on his belly moves
so all these fighters they believe they
have to do three times a week four times
a week an hour beating exercise guys i'm
talking about four minutes a day and if
you're a professional fighter make it
five minutes and do it before a workout
which you're going to do anyway warm up
your diaphragm and you watch after 30
days watch your muscles get trained it's
resistance training it's weight training
for your breathing muscles see it like
that you know and you're gonna have to
find a cap
that you can do it oh this is another
thing this is important tim don't don't
fall in the trap that you want to do the
smallest setting right away in the
shortest time don't do that i used to do
that and i was able to do 30 repetitions
in two minutes at 15 seconds
and i thought i was such a stud and then
dr beliza told me i wasn't completely
inhaling once i started doing that it
became six and a half minutes
so then i went to decrease the size i
give you another one if you go all the
way back on my facebook page there's a
facebook page called boss rutens o2 boot
camp it's for all o2 trainer users bass
witness o2 boot camp
you can go all the way back to 2018 may
2018 this is where i started
that setting i used it took me it was
setting number four with the the new
autotrader setting number four it took
me three minutes and 45 seconds to
complete 30 repetitions two years later
just for fun i said to my wife i'm going
to use that same setting again because
now i was much stronger i did with the
same setting i did it in 55 seconds so i
went from three minutes of 45 seconds to
55 seconds that's a 75 percent increase
it's bizarre so that's what happens when
you train your breathing muscles and
once you train them they don't steal
have to steal blood anymore from your
other muscles so you stop gassing you
delay your gassing
way further
oh my god i might finally have
endurance better than homer simpson for
the first time in my life i'm excited
about this
well
boss
you're a lot of fun you're a maniac and
i love it so
thank you
yeah that's a compliment people can find
you of course on twitter instagram at
boss food and mma
we'll link to everything facebook pages
the youtube pages also
o2
trainer.com as you mentioned
and also all this all the social handles
and youtube channel youtube.com o2
trainer so easy to find is there
anything else that you would like to
point people to any last
comments parting thoughts complaints
that you'd like to air publicly
yeah so like i said that seven skills to
save your life with amir perez you
should really youtube this guy so you
have an idea what he can do he's a
bizarre
so craftmargot.com
boss bas then you can go to that side
then the
breathing4warriors.com go to that course
check it out it's a whole it's there's
nothing on the market like that not and
people by the way if you do belizea
vranic stick severance and wim hof
studies love graph book deco tech
there's so many different reading
programs programs it doesn't matter this
makes it better why because you're
working out the muscles responsible for
breathing they will teach you the
technique this will give you the
endurance and the power in order to do
it and the last thing i have is the body
action system bas body access system is
a punching and kicking device that i
created like 11 years ago and that's
going really well the ufc actually sells
it now as well and you can beat the crap
out of it and it won't break and it's
like a real head not like different
targets because you don't fight multiple
people no one had one body with targets
on it you hit that thing there's no
impact for your joints you're gonna
leave all your joints nice and smooth
and you can hit it like a real person
it's a real fun little thing to watch so
uh google them as well please
we will link to all those things in the
show notes at tim dot blog slash podcast
and you will be there there will not be
another person named boss written on the
podcast you can just search boss bas and
i'm sure it'll pop
right up well boss you know i hope
someday we have a chance to
break some bread or have a coffee or
maybe have a green tea yeah instead of a
cup of urine
you heard that right you ever heard that
wait which is this his family in the
morning they drink their own pee i did
not know this no yeah okay okay that's a
whole different level i wouldn't do that
that'll be round two with boss
so yeah
protocol number one 30 days of o2
trainer and for people who are not
watching the video it's something you
can stick in a pocket it's not a large
device so just for a sort of a visual
cue it looks looks like a a mouth guard
with a very small
it's not a pipe but it's a very small
sort of appendage on front it's it's
something that you could easily travel
with
and
nice to spend time with you boss thank
you vel yes
was a lot of fun i i'm so happy
especially all the questions about
pridefinding championships and to have a
person who actually lived in japan as
well so that's always refreshing
yeah it's a great time and
take care and i really appreciate you
and certainly for all of the years of
entertainment and excitement and also
for you carving out the time and space
to have this conversation today thank
you very much oh sue that's what we said
you